so development controlled be on the 8th
of July 2020 welcome to the meeting my
name is Cathy Guthrie and I'm the
chairman today May are first of all
remind you of some domestic arrangements
please insure microphones are muted when
you are not speaking that you do not
interrupt the other speaker members are
reminded that we're not using the
messaging your checked facility members
are reminded they should not have
alternative communication lines open and
that if you are contacted by a third
party an application you should during
the application you should bring this to
the legal adviser semester to range
moose that if you are eliciting the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave additionally you will be
invited to speak and ask questions by
the chair myself as the meeting please
await your turn we won't be using the
hands up function except for
declarations of interest site visits or
declarations of lobbying if you are
experiencing poor connection issues in
the first instance please turn off your
camera if this does not work please turn
off all incoming video these options are
under the three dots in your main
information bar I would like to remind
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to the internet and
will be capable of repeated viewing the
whole of the meeting will be recorded
except where there are confidential
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented being recorded by entering
this meeting as a speaker you are also
consenting to being recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
sound and recordings for webcasting and
for training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully excluded I'll now do
introductions in Despres the legal
adviser good morning madam chairman
ladies and gentlemen
thank you Robert Carmichael governance
officer want you John Bateman G area
planning manager a good morning and just
also just after that I'm not sharing
video unfortunately I don't have a video
capacity on my surface pro so therefore
I can't say I do thank you okay thank
you Alex Scott the case officer for this
first application please yes thank you
madam chairman members all right we'll
get you and when you give us the
presentation we'll see you
so can I move on to the agenda please I
will now ask the governance officer to
roll call for members present Thank You
chair if you could please respond with
present all good morning so accounts the
James Karsten present councillor Peter
Gould present councillor Cathy Guthrie
present castor Barry Humphries present
councillor Andrew Mellon present
councillor Mike Norris
Andrew stringer present and cast around
rollin war boys present Thank You chair
we are all present excellent moving on
to item 2 to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members if there are any to declare
please use the hands up function
no thank you
moving on declarations of lobbying if
there are any to declare please use the
homes up function Andrew Mellon
councillor Mullen could you tell us
please yes chair I just like to declare
that I've had a discussion on the
membership application with the the ward
member mr. stringer thank you for that
declarations of personal site visits and
I'm actually going to put my hand up and
from the point of view I drove past the
a second application site to go and get
my eggs from the egg dispensary and I
drove past the site thank you
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 28th of April 2020
are there any points regarding accuracy
of the minutes please and then again
please put your hands up and I will come
to you then
so there are none so if you are happy
from page seven to page 12 I will sign
them but did you want to go through a
roll call second to go through a roll
call may I have a proposer please
councillor stringer yes proposer under
seconder please
yes Catalan Thank You Jess I'll go
through the roll call so if you could
please respond with four against or
abstain so councillor James Karsten for
councillor Peter Gould Oh Kathy Guthrie
Oh
councillor barry humphries fall Andrew
stringer for and castor boys for Thank
You chair that is unanimous and carried
so the minutes will be signed at the
next practicable availability to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme none
receive chair
the schedule of the planning
applications we will move to the first
item and it should be noted that items 7
v delta charlie oblique 1 9 of leek oh
five nine four nine land to the
northwest of mason court brackets old
engine meadow has been withdrawn by
officers with my agreement and will not
be considered today so can we just have
a brief update from the area planning
manager to give us a short overview as
to why this matter won't be heard please
like you the matter in question it's
come to light that there were agreement
over amended plans coming forward and it
was seen to be inappropriate to take
this forward to committee without
exploring those other options now it is
a case of reasonable behavior and we
have taken the decision to take it away
from committee to consider these
alternative plans and then return it to
committee when we're in an agreed
position so we apologize for this we
don't want to be seen as unnecessary
work and unreasonable behavior
especially if the decision was to be one
of refusal and we ended up at appeal so
on the basis of risk we have decided to
withdraw the appeal module the committee
item thank you for that
so we now move to the case officer Alex
Scott to introduce the application to
the committee and I think at this point
if people could just turn off their
videos so that the presentation can be
clear but I will keep mine on if
everybody's happy with that so Alex over
to you please okay thank you chairman
members and everybody present this is
item 7a
in your papers planning application
reference PC 1905 nine one five lab
north of Chapel Road in Mendelssohn and
the application seeks outline planning
from
with all matters reserved safer access
matters of access are to be considered
today for the erection of 20 new
dwellings and creation of a new access
to Chapel Road Rendlesham the proposal
includes seven affordable housing that's
35 percent of the total and
approximately five thousand nine hundred
fifty square meters of open space
indicated to be between the proposed
housing and the countryside to a north
west edge of the village and this
equates to approximately 1215 square
meters of formal public open space and
four thousand seven hundred and
thirty-four square meters of informal
open space including sustainable
drainage infrastructure the proposal
also includes the provision of a
footpath link from the site along the
chapel road frontage and linking into
the villages existing paved footpath
network at Mayfield Way which is
adjacent to the south east of a site the
proposal would also implement
sustainability energy efficiency
measures agreed in principle with your
environmental protection officers in
terms of background and history the
application follows a previous
application for 49 Wellings on the site
which was refused by committee
on the 16th of October last year for the
reasons that it was considered contrary
to plan policy mp1 that's of the
neighborhood plan which prefers
proposals of 20 dwellings or less in
such locations which are outside of but
immediately adjacent to the existing
village settlement boundary furthermore
it was considered contrary to policy mp1
on the grounds that the indicative
layout presented for the 49 dwellings
was not considered appropriate and
sympathetic to the area and not
sufficiently cohesive of the existing
village members considered the proposal
did not make good use of planting and
softening to the edges of the
development and the new development
sorry the new dwellings were not
considered to demonstrate efficiency
energy usage and use of renewable energy
and your officers consider that the
current proposal to have sufficiently
addressed the reasons previously given
for refusal the proposal is now 420
dwellings which we consider satisfies
plan policy mp1 there is a significant
amount of soft landscaping which is now
proposed to the northwest side of a site
creating a soft green buffer to this
edge of the village and a sustainability
energy scheme has been proposed and
accepted by your environmental
protection officers as I mentioned
earlier which would exceed building
regulations reducing energy demand by
approximately 64 percent it adopts a
fabric first approach to reduce carbon
emissions and solar panels air source
heat pumps would be used for primary
sources of heating and garages would be
equipped with electric charging points
so if I move to the presentation try
that get that on the screen for you
hopefully this works
starting the slideshow from the
beginning and may I ask if you can see
that chairman and everybody else yes I
can just everybody just tell us if they
can't I I hope they can but I'll move
through the presentation now and you do
that Alex if you took your own video
because that did better sorry too
I will do that now Robert turning off
video right there any possibility of
making the presentation bigger is this
just mine
no that's what it is I'm afraid okay
thank you
okay so I'll I'll start from the
beginning of the presentation so this is
the initial page give me application
number and the site location a little
bit slow on my screen apologies this
first slide is the site location for the
avoidance of doubt the location of the
village of Mendel shown within the
district this slide is the general
location of the site within the village
itself so we have the a 140 here
mountain village so it's to the to the
north of the village there and this is
the exact site location in the context
of it surrounds adjacent to existing
developments fronting the opposite side
of Chapel Road here and it may field
right way here this existing development
this is the constraints map of the of
the village and the area of the site the
site itself is edged in red the blue
line here represents the settlement
boundary as defined in the current
development plan the thick blue areas
define flood risk zones as specified by
the Environment Agency the purple line
is the boundary of the village
Conservation Area and the colored
buildings you may be able to see those
are listed buildings by grade 1 listed
buildings such as the Church
shown in green great two-star buildings
shown in red and the orange color
denotes great 2 listed buildings and the
most relevant one is here that I just
might be able to see I've got a closer
up image later but that's a fetched
cottage known as car pick tile which is
on the opposite side of the road to the
development slide 6 so this is a aerial
photograph of the site and area this is
the site location plan submitted with
the application and this is the
indicative site plan provided now it's
important to note that matters of layout
and landscaping are presently reserved
and this is indicative information only
showing how it could work but matters of
access are for full consideration and
they close up of the proposed access and
you might just be able to see the
connecting foot way most of the existing
Road side verge linking into my field
way here which is part of the proposal
and listed building grade 2 is in this
location here for you some street scene
elevations but these again are
indicative they're not for full
consideration today but just for
information on how such a scheme may may
look onto the site photographs this the
Chapel Road site frontage and the
location of the proposed access will be
in this location adjacent to the
existing public footpath which runs
along
the along the southeast boundary of the
site between that and they may feel way
this is a reverse view looking back into
the village and this is the listed
building here at Casa Patel this is the
interior of the site frontage looking
back across the field where the
development is proposed and to the
building's adjacent to the edge of the
village existing and along here is a
line of trees and beyond that to the
left is the is the main highway and this
is a view back to the start of the
public right-of-way and then as it
continues along the existing edge of the
village here and we have existing
landscape screening high hedges and a
ditch which runs along this this
boundary drainage ditch this is taken
from the rear of the site and the
existing footpath here and screening and
back towards the chapel road frontage
you might be able to make out existing
buildings across the road frontage and
this is from the the northeast corner of
the site to the rear looking back
towards the dwellings along Mayfield way
in the distance just poking out above
the existing screening there some larger
two-story buildings at the back of the
estate there and to the e street scene
this is the existing building listed
grade 2 listed cars picked L and
adjacent to it is a a building which is
not listed but your heritage officers
considered to be a non designated
heritage assets our cottage significant
age and character it is believed this is
taken from the entrance to Mayfield Way
adjacent to the site and looking back
towards the village give you some idea
of the existing character and then back
into Mayfield Way itself which would be
adjacent to the the proposed development
this is an aerial view of the site and
area and this is the field in question
here on the edge of the village
and this is the old engine meadow site
which has approval for 28 dwellings in
outline form with reserve matters still
to be considered and in terms of updates
it's been brought to my attention that
since writing the report three letters
in support of the application have
indeed been received and that's been
confirmed and in summary representers
think that this is much-needed
development of small houses and
bungalows available to perhaps
first-time buyers and those wishing to
downsize it produce it proposes a large
amount of public open space to the edge
of the village
writers consider it has minimal impact
on the village they support the
sustainable approach writers do not
consider the proposal would result in
significant traffic issues they consider
the development to be well positioned
and the proposal is noted to be close to
the village health center and it's
considered that this would be of benefit
to families and the elderly in
particular and for the avoidance of that
the officers have considered the
officers and your consul teas in fact
have considered the s
a scoping an environmental report and
traffic movement report documents
produced by the neighborhood Planning
Group in performing the formal
recommendation before you today and this
is set at in the in the report for you
and your officers recommendation is for
approval subject to completion of
section 106 and conditions as set out in
your report papers Thank You chair thank
you for that so can we move to questions
from the members of the planning officer
please
so counselor war boys would you like to
have any questions for the officer
please okay that's it that's it yeah
yes so to be clear here the originally
the officers recommendation was to
refuse this but has the the number of
houses has been reduced and there's been
better standards been proposed in
regards to energy efficiency then the
officers recommendation now is to accept
their motion to approve the application
yes I mean the the previous application
for 49 was was considered by members at
add committee and it was the it was the
members recommendation actually actually
contrary to an officer recommendation at
that time but so that that shouldn't
matter is the council's decision at at
the end of a day and that said that the
the reasons for for refusal officers
have assessed that as part of as a
material consideration in coming to the
recommendations with respect to this
application and it's considered that the
reasons previously given for refusal
have been suited
addressed okay so thank you can't I'll
come back to you counselor stringers
board member castle and Norris do you
have any questions yes just the one is
Chapel Road HOF which this development
is proposed subject to a thirty mile an
hour speed limit yes I believe it is yes
okay that's all I have thank you
thank you councillor Mellon do you have
questions for the officer yes think that
you have a couple of questions just
looking at the indicated layer it seems
to show that the existing public
right-of-way is being retained in its
existing format that that's correct is
it yes in fact improvements have been
advised by Suffolk County Council and we
expect those to be carried forward so it
will be retained and improved that's the
proposal thank you and the second
question I had was an on slide five in
your presentation I don't know if you're
allowed to show that again or possible
to show that again yes sorry I'll try
and get it back up for you
I'd five constraints map yes yes well I
can't say at the moment but anyway the
question is all sorry I'm like yeah
apologies right I need to be present
hopefully that's are you I would to see
that night council he hasn't come
through yet
I can ask my question anyway and my
question was it seems to be a little out
of date that that slide I believe
there's being quite a considerable
amount of development off what is the
row called old station road I think to
the west of old station road there's a
development there which doesn't seem to
have appeared on your map no indeed this
is a yeah this is a rather old map and
has not been updated yet but yet the
development in question was to the yet
to the to the west of old station Road
on the old
Jia Jia warehousing site I believe and
that is currently underdeveloped and
nearing completion I understand but yes
there may be a few developments since
this was published I don't have an exact
date of when when this was but yeah yes
apologies as there's little I can do
about that I'm afraid just just a point
out you know from my knowledge where
where those developments would be okay
thank you no further questions Thank You
councillor Mallon councillor Humphreys
any questions for the officer no
questions thank you
Thank You councillor gold any questions
for the officer thank so first a more
technical question which I think I know
the answer to but I just want to be
certain
which is the the neighborhood mention
neighborhood plan is being reviewed at
the moment but there's an existing
adopted neighborhood plan is this I just
wanted to check on the status of the
adopted neighborhood plan presumably
that remains in force and then till and
unless replaced okay if I could have to
defer to the area planning manager to us
at that point please I'm aware Oh crumbs
I'm here myself
again can you hear me now yeah sorry I
hit the wrong button they went back all
myself could hear myself very loudly I
don't like the sound of my voice must
have been I have got something prepared
to talk about in respect of the current
neighborhood plan and the revised
neighborhood plan now I can go through
that now if wishes me to or I can come
in later I'm happy to answer that in its
entirety to give us the full views first
and then perhaps if Peter could bear
with us and the question might be
answered both with the ward members
input and then the senior planning
manager area planning manager later
would that be okay with you please okay
Council England absolutely very happy
for for that just one other matter
could we be advised of the the grade of
the agricultural land involved in the
site he's described in the
representation section as prime
agricultural land that could just be
clarified please thank you yes I think
could you look look into that for us and
give us an update at a short Lea after
Alex please unless you know it now
German are already right now I can look
that up I'll give you the answer in a
few minutes thank you John thank you
okay so you know thank you very much for
that counselor go now counselor Caston
do you have some questions please thank
you madam chairman um Elisabet concerned
this development that some that's
happened in this village that we can't
see on the map I would like to UM the
officer t-1 pointing that out so it's
absolutely clear to me where the this
developments carried out of kind of um I
don't know the the road names and that
round Wendell Sherman them I'd like to
know where that is for this some
decision Liam the other thing I wonder
if I could talk about is the UM this is
the suds the young's whale at the end of
the development the bottom that backs on
to potentially the floodplain of the i
assume it's the Gipping coming coming
through the you know that armor that
side side of the development i do we do
we know what the issues could possibly
be with that floodplain being right
beside a suds if the system if the if
the water level rises high enough which
it would potentially flood that and the
suds in a time when the suds is
desperately needed to get water runoff
away from the development and the
obviously that would only happen at a
time when the water level is very high
in the given do wium do we have any
other do we haven't do you have any more
information on how that would work of
seeing Liam the assessment that the the
flood risk assessment but I just I just
consider that quite close to that swale
okay so a couple of points there I'll
try and get the map up again for you so
we can
trying to explain where a few of the
developments may be sure my screen okay
are you able to see that counselor the
the map of the village
yes thinking thank you thank you very
much
right so current developments down here
there has been approved that's gone
through outline and reserved matters and
is currently being built what's known as
the gr warehousing site sort proper
proximately this scale new housing and
there's been an outline application
approved for development south of bleep
way here although we still need reserved
reserved matters through on on that one
and there's been a I think to two
dwellings approved along the road in
this location as well and up here at
what's known as old engine meadow there
is a an outline approval for the
twenty-eight dwellings but that is an
outline form at the moment and we still
need reserves on that one so I believe
just one significant development in
addition to what you can see there at
the moment
the others are an outline approval form
only and we still need follow-on
reserved matters so those will may be
coming forward in the future and
elsewhere a little bit of infill
development which I I don't have the
comprehensive list I'm afraid but I
think those are the significant ones if
that's if that's helpful if I can move
so you can just point out the a14
direction from that from that map there
yes indeed yes if we can come to the
wider view so we have Mendel's from here
the a14 is runs here through the village
it's only like that through the district
sorry
and the a 140 that's north to south
connecting the a 14-2 to Norfolk and
Norwich have you been able to see that
gem so you can just see that you know
it's quite small but no from yeah I can
I can see from I'm up here here and I
can yeah I understand that now thank you
very much and Caston did you have the
issue regarding the location of the Sun
since well did you have that
sufficiently answered for you um well no
not really I'm not sure if there's some
what my worry is that this am there's an
engineering issue there with a with a
floodplain and a subsystem I'd quite
like someone to tell me that there is an
Orem or explain that a bit further right
well I mean what I can tell you is we've
had a comprehensive strategic flood risk
assessment completed by the by the
applicant this has gone to the local
leap flood authority at Suffolk County
Council for full consideration now all
the all the sustainability drainage
infrastructure will be suitably
attenuated and allowed to drain to
ground naturally and the main sub
feature is the the attenuation Basin you
can see here now that is that is
indicative in terms of location and
scale at the moment but it just gives an
idea of what what the proposal could be
and we are dealing with matters of
principle at the moment
and flood risk and surface water
drainage have been considered in
principle and the advice of the local
lead flood authority is that it's
acceptable subject to further conditions
of detail which we were able to secure
by way of conditions so it has been
considered and addressed in principle is
all I can say there yes thank you for
that Alex I mean it does say that on
page 23 that it is that subject to
conditions so I hope that answers your
question counselor Kirsten yes thank you
very much madam chairman right I don't
have any questions but I will come back
um counsel a stringer do you have any
questions for the officer at all yes
thank you chair yes I have three one you
made you may comment about letters of
support are they on top of the letter of
support coming in from Norwich Road
Claydon in January because they're not
on the website and if you mention them
in your your presentation it would be
nice for us to be able to be able to
access them okay these were yeah these
were brought to my attention yesterday
actually in terms in terms of them being
on the on the website yeah I mean it's
my understanding that we don't usually
post third-party letters can I just ask
the and everybody we do afraid we do can
I just check that with the area matter
if I may come in German no we don't
actually put all letters received on the
website there are reasons that we don't
do that the basis that sometimes they
are accusation 'el and we would be
liable for that so we don't always place
all letters on the website it also
depends on the format that they come in
sometimes they come online through the
sometimes they come by an email
sometimes they come in a post and it
does depend on the time between the
submission and going on the website in
terms of how the support team have been
able to redact the information to of
course we can't put certain sensitive
data protection information online the
the person's signature for example that
put on the third party so no it is
actually a discretionary matter of
putting all letters on the website but
saying that we try to wherever we can
Alex though what I need from you is just
confirm the exact number of support and
objections for me just to confirm that
once and for all please yes I can
if you just bear with me I believe we
have three letters of supports in total
that's including the the ones I was made
aware of yesterday if I can just double
check the just looking at the report now
double checking the number I said in the
yes 24 letters of concern or objection
as set out in the report and three
letters three letters of support in
total thank you and just before we go
inside forgive me counselor if we go
further questions just to confirm from
an earlier question the land in terms of
agricultural use I've got as grade three
but I'm not aware of any Pacific survey
on the land that's the general
allocation of grade across the area and
the majority of it is grade three thank
you and councillor string do you think
those three of support includes the ones
that you were referring to
well there's one that we've published on
our website and that comes from Norwich
Road Clayton
and not that it's a it's a race about
how many people object or or support but
you know support from Caden I probably
don't use it give quite as much way to
support from as an address right
opposite of site well I think I think we
know we get lots of letters from all
over the place the officers take a
pragmatic view of the course members
can't see the content and that's why
your your report your presentation
mentioned a footpath link to the
services of Mendel shown now the
footpath link that you demonstrated was
not the one being asked by condition by
the officer on page 51 on page 51 the
officer is asked that they would require
a footway link two ducks in road to make
a continuous link to bus stops
facilities and the primary school I mean
my reading of the word continuous link
would would need road crossings have you
seen a plan of this continuous link at
all because if our officers are asking
for it to be conditioned and you haven't
shown us that link in your presentation
there is some ambiguity there which I
think needs to be in front of members
Alex and then we can see what councillor
stringer is advising us yeah
[Music]
[Music]
right so as I understand what is what is
part of the proposal would be a four
part link along the road frontage here
to - may feel way and then that in turn
would link through the existing footpath
network to the to the center of the
village that's my that's my
understanding of bits on the table but
Alex it doesn't that's the problem it
would require an awful lot of
engineering to have a continuous link to
ducts in Road and that's what the office
is asking for you to insist upon right
okay okay well yeah I took out a point
but I believe this proposal okay
can I my last question has the officers
taken into account the impact of
approving this application on the
published Amendment of Mendelssohn
neighborhood plan may I can one on this
one yes I think this this would be
something that would help us all yes
please thank you right I'm just
respecting the footpath I respectfully
also will point out to members that we
have an outline approval for Mason's
Court opposite this site that outline
approval includes direct linkage to the
village and that is part of the
agreement of that application so in
terms of material consideration that is
a significant military material
consideration in terms of connectivity
because it will be available through
that outline which I understand is a an
allocation in the future will be through
that outline to get to the village as
well as the link to May Mayfield
way within the this proposal and
supported by Suffolk County Council so I
will just put that into the members
consideration later in the debate in
terms of the neighborhood
plan but the simple answer is yes we
have considered the revised neighborhood
plan as well as the current neighborhood
plan and again I'm happy to go through
that in detail if this is the opportune
moment to do that yes I think you should
moment because with respect to
councillor stringer he's brought this
issue up and I think we need to address
it for him but I think councillor
stringer you'll see you're not in it in
the debate you'll talk to us when you
get absolutely good I before we move on
to that can I just
the there was a statement made about the
footpath which is actually completely
untrue this site is not opposite
Mayfield way it's sorry not opposite
Mason core you cannot walk on a footpath
from this site - Mason Court I'm very
sorry we need to get the map something
look this is absolutely critical because
there was there was advice from our
policy officers about this particular
site regarding connectivity that the
County Council is trying to address and
the plans before us at the moment do not
okay we can put the plant up please alex
is up against only right so we have the
you need to probably go with one a bit
wider that's all that's that's the link
to along the road itself we have a path
up to this point indicative of course no
I in the context of there is two
properties opposite you have to kind of
go round in order to get into the old my
Masons quartzite I withdraw that comment
you would need to cross the road at that
point and I accept I'm not aware that
there's a footpath for that short piece
of land there I don't know how why that
would be 20 30 meters is that
satisfactory I'm sorry again you're
pointing to the entrance to the health
center but gia gated that's not the
footpath you're talking about the okay I
have to go back over the line permission
for the Oldman oranga Meadows side to
side then important we get this right
for the time being for the route to
allow this to go forward let's just
accept that the current application in
what it is proposing is simply the
connection along the road itself which
would then lead into the village via
that route before you want screaming
yeah and could show that route from
Mayfield way into the village very flat
path that would be really helpful
Alex I assume you can go from a footpath
all the way from the entrance of the
site through to some part of the village
where I don't know
not without crossing the road there is
no that you would have to either side of
the road I think cats councillor
stringer you've made your point on that
but I mean many villages you have to
cross roads to get to places but the
connectivity shall we say from your
point of view is lean and lesser than
you had hoped is is that the would that
be a current and that was the original
policy response from our Council yeah
okay so the highways have accepted it in
their plans at the moment and the
planning officer has been given the
details thus far so yeah no that's
exactly what I said the officer at the
county council has asked for it to go
further and I was questioning how far it
is going to go that's what I was
questioning can I just also make one
further point and I appreciate we might
be steering into debate slightly here
okay there was not a reason for refusal
on the previous application and I will
be careful on that point when we come to
the debate okay I think you've made the
point there councillors stringer and
that will be food for thought in the
debate as you quite rightly point out
John and
so moving on from questions thank you
for those questions councillor stringer
can we move on to the public speakers
now please and we have the parish
council representative mr. Michael Exley
and you have three minutes to address
the committee if you would please and
please turn on your video and then we
can see you oh you are Thank You chair
good morning could you hear me we can
yes okay thank you
medical parish council have already
given a full response to this planning
application recommending and refused and
so if I will only dwell on a few points
particularly the Suffolk County Council
response at the 20th of January which
again is referring to mr. stringers
comments they require a foot way linked
to Ducks from Road to make continuous
link to bus stops facilities and a
school and they suggest a condition that
a foot way is to provide it in its
entirety before the development is
brought into use members from parish
council have continuously raised in its
responses the doubt that such a
condition can be fulfilled in its
entirety should we not have clear
documentation that this footpath is
possible with clearly identified land
ownership for its whole length showing
that this land is under control of the
applicant at the moment all we had is a
red line on a map it may well be that
such a condition is undeliverable and
therefore its site the site itself
undeliverable there's also a Suffolk
County Council response of the 5th of
February regarding the flood risk now
this site actually flows into the river
dark a CH meant it already takes all the
surface water from Chapel Road and old
engine meadow which is either health
center you've already discussed also
will be put in water into the into the
Dove above this site we don't seem to
have a very detailed flood risk
assessment on this site should this also
not be resolved before planning approval
is given just to mention a couple of
inaccuracies in the offices report
number one stroke five no bus stop
exists in Chapel Road five five chapel
road at the southern end is within the
conservation area the historic
conservation area is the church Church
Road Chapel Road and Old Market Street
and Front Street all traffic from this
site must pass through the Conservation
Area medicines revised neighborhood plan
SC a document is given weight by the
officers in this and recommending
approval of the site yet this same
document also support our alternative
allocated site to the south of the
parish which contains such factors as
less flood risk good footpaths close to
extensive play areas school and less
traffic to the conservation area this
makes our alternative site far more
preferable that's all I have to say
thank you very much thank you for that
so and do members have questions for mr.
Exley castle walk but no questions in
this moment councillor Norris
councillor Norris do you have any
questions for mr. Exley sorry I hadn't
unmuted my mic no no questions thank you
Thank You councillor Malan yes Thank You
chair just one question
this is reference to the parish councils
submission in writing can you confirm
the number of homes which have received
permission in Mendelssohn already prior
to this application
Thank You councillor Humphreys do you
have any questions no thank you mums you
Catholic gold No thank you madam chair
councillor Caston no thank you madam
chair Thank You mr. Exley and Thank You
mr. Exley I don't have any questions for
you so if you would now like to switch
off your video and continue to listen to
the meeting thank you very much
did you switch off your video cancer mr.
Exley it tells me it's turned off but is
it not turned off no I can see you thank
you so now we have an objective mr.
Terry Moore to speak would you like to
turn your video on please and can we
hear you for three minutes if you would
please thank you very much good morning
Mendelson through its adopted
neighborhood development plan has
already demonstrated its commitment to
new development its current plan target
of 75 new dwellings for the period 2016
2 2013 one has already been met and
surpassed 2 over 100 dwellings we
started a review of our adoptive plan in
2017 identifying possible future sites
in October of that year we consulted
with our residents on possible size
overwhelmingly a site to the south of
the village adjacent to glebe Way was
selected the Chapel Road site was
identified as the least desirable since
then our neighborhood planning committee
spent a considerable amount of time
effort and finance to confirm the most
suitable sites for further future
development on the advice of Miss
Suffolk officers we commissioned
external professional organizations to
provide detailed assessments of all
possible development sites that work is
now complete and a draft revised
emerging neighborhood development plan
is publicly available on the parish
councils website the current joint local
plan draft joint local plan has a target
minimum of 161 new properties for the
period April twenty eighteen to twenty
thirty six member shows emerging plan
shows in detail how that figure will be
met and surpassed Mendel shenmue
residents did not support the chapel
road site the ever increase in traffic
flows are affecting the historic core of
our village it's conservation area the
Chapel Road
does nothing to improve that situation
it will worsen it by the introduction of
yet more traffic pedestrian access to
the site is not straightforward and the
problems with local flooding persists
the primary aim of our emerging plan is
to show clearly where future development
will be best placed residents have
clearly indicated that that further
development should be to the south of
the village adjacent to grid way it is
frustrating that officers are ignoring
the bigger picture presented in our
emerging plan and also echoed in our
responses to the draft joint Local Plan
residents recognised the need for
ongoing development and have willingly
participated in the work that has led to
the production of the emerging plan it
should also be noted that membership has
now set up its own Community Land Trust
identifying a potential site that
mentioned green for up to 10 new
dwellings this is not NIMBYism nor is it
a reluctance to accept change it is
simply a community putting forward a
clear programme on how it wants to
comply with local planning and
development for the future I ask that
you acknowledge their commitment and
reject this application thank you thank
you
doing have questions and for mr. Moore
counselor war boys sorry I I am very
concerned about the deliverability of
the of this plan councillor stringers
already talked a little bit about the
footpath of you got the delivery of the
footpath into the tap have you got
anything to that you could add to that
at all I'm not sure I understand that
question
sorry it was counsel stringer talked
about the deliberate the possibility of
the footpath connecting this site into
the center of the mendel sure have you
got anything to add to that at all in
terms of you
neighbourhood plan no I don't think we
have I mean we've we've looked at that
particular site it the footpath is just
one aspect of it personally I think that
footpath is going to be very difficult
to deliver and it's the type of thing
that really should properly explore it
probably needs a site visit which we're
not going to do today but it is about
the importance of access into the center
of the village and whilst as the crow
flies it's very close to the center of
the village I have no doubt
unfortunately residents don't have the
abilities of crows to get there and they
have to negotiate crossing several
different roads to really to get to a
point where they can access the centre
of the village and even access to the
local surgery would be difficult the
road there is narrowing it's on a long
sweeping Bend it's not one of the safest
places around the village and we've got
to be careful that we're not entering
into debate here we want quite good
thank you for your all those who've lie
obviously primed to to give us your full
reply there so where are we now
councillor sorry that was councillor
Mellon was it no that's councillor war
boys so to cancel the Norris No thank
you no question as such I'll wait for
the debate thank you Thank You
councillor melon
no questions Thank You councillor
Humphreys no questions thank you Gold no
questions thank you and councillor
Caston thank you madam chairman um mr.
Moore you mentioned existing flooding
issues in the village you can just talk
to us a little bit about those stick in
fact well hang on a minute we can't have
a debate here councillor Caston a very
brief response please what are the known
floods I think it's already been
addressed in in the debate in their
papers but a very brief response please
I think
shall we say the area around the chip
from sort of the chip shop down to the
surgery the doctor surgery well known
for frequent flooding we are constantly
told that it is easy to rectify but it
still keeps happening all right thank
you for that and that's a current
situation that we obviously don't want
to exacerbate but equally we can't solve
from this development on a current
matter so a question from councillor
stringer if you would please I have no
questions Thank You councillor stringer
we don't thank you very much mr. Moore
if you'd like to switch your video off
now and thank you very much for your
time thank you
we don't have a supporter so I now ask
the applicant David Barker to speak you
have three minutes to address the
committee and I know you've got two
other people there but I think if you
give us your presentation and then when
the questions come up and again please
be wary that we're not going into debate
on it it's just clarity and quick
questions please thank you so off you go
mr. Barker thank you a good morning
following the last committee this
proposal has been reduced from 49 to 20
homes with two acres of public open
space giving her well lands pay
attentions to the village this is four
times more public open space than the
earlier proposal the open space will be
in the most prominent western part of
the site the site will be developed at a
lower density compared to the old engine
bed a site opposite which was approved
at 28 homes in 2018 a planning condition
can be used to require that reserved
matters follow the principles of this
outlined application the adopted and
impact this proposal is supported by an
energy statement which shows significant
reductions in energy usage of after 64
percent can be achieved there's current
building regulations this commitment
goes well beyond anything proposed on
other housing sites and membership or in
the existing or draft neighbourhood
plans these measures can be required by
a condition to ensure the final scheme
is sustainable
the doctors neighborhood plan requires
that sufficient infrastructure is
provided for new homes no jep's has been
received from the console T's on
educational health it will receive a
loss EPS a hardware consultant says that
he's carried out three traffic service
including one in February well before
lockdown these show that a peak times
Old Market Street will only have three
extra vehicles an hour on Front Street
and extra for vehicles now construction
traffic can be routed away from these
areas there's a minimal increases in
traffic new foot ways will provide a
pedestrian link into the village best
benefiting existing and new residents
and these are shown in the submitted
highways report that comes with this
application in appendices B and C these
say the highways boundary and the routes
of the new footpath that would link to
Mayfield way an existing footpaths in
that area this route or just be occasion
and has been considered in there and
response which is a point of support
subject to conditions drainage engineer
says the site can be properly trained
and fully meets county standards
society's downstream of the nearby 28
home sites that would not affect that
site a large area of landscape frontage
will be framed by homes to give an
attractive edge to the village
approaching the village old engine
Meadow will be seen first and will be
prominent in views towards the village
this proposal complies with the adopted
neighborhood plan which wants to see
small developments around the edge of
the village which this is the emerging
neighborhood plan as little wait at this
point however its policies would also
permit this development the last
application on this site was refused as
wait could not be given to the draft
district plan so we cannot now be given
four very early draft neighbourhood plan
to object-- to this proposal and the
adopted plan is the basis for decision
making this is the most sustainably
designed and well landscape developments
of this scale and I've been involved
with everything provost games in the
area I'm happy to answer any questions
and have our clients highways and
drainage engineer's with me to assist
you if necessary thank you thank you we
did some lose you here and there but we
did get
most of the I got most of the words can
I just ask my fellow committee members
just to say if they're happy with what
they've heard and they heard it
sufficiently well enough if you didn't
let me know but if you did just a few
seconds to say right I think we got we
got most of what you heard thank you I
just wanted to give you the opportunity
there were just a few moments that it
locked a little so can we have questions
for the applicants and I'll go first
- counselor wall boys please yes thank
you chairman you you mentioned you
Appendix C which has did did you it was
a little bit unclear but did you infer
that those drawings to show the actual
footpaths linking this site to the
village hello can you hear me yes good
yes it was a little faint and councilor
war boys but I think I got the gist of
your question so I'm forgive me if I
don't answer completely yes I made the
point in my presentation that this
application is supported by a highway
statement which has two appendices
appendices B and C though show the
adopted Hart will the highways boundary
and they also show a plan prepared by a
highways consultant that shows a new
footpath linking to the existing
footpaths Mayfield way that report is
probably part of the application and was
considered by and highways officers when
they gave their consultation response to
this application so I hope that provides
and some of the clarity that you're
looking for on those footpath links
thank you for that it certainly does for
me counselor wool boys is that all right
can we move on yes thank you thank you
council of war boys councillor Norris
any questions for the applicant
oh no further questions Thank You
councillor Mullen
yes Thank You chair I've got a question
just going back and trying to sort of
dig a bit deeper on this access and
footpaths issue I don't feel we have the
appendices in the bundle but what we do
have is the the 20th of January letter
from Suffolk County Council highways
which requests a footway link it's a
ducts and Road and I'm still not
entirely clear in my mind that the
applicants or you as the agent will be
able to provide that it's about
two-thirds of the way down page 51 in
the bundle yes I can I can help with
that and if I have my highways
consultant and you being with me so
maybe I found you you could help if
there's anything I miss what they should
what and Andrew Bingham has designed
isn't is a new foot way that goes on
land that he's been advised is within
the highway boundary that links to an
existing foot way of Mayfield way you
would reach that foot where you were
then cross Mayfield way to get to a foot
we're on the other side and then you
would cross the road and that would get
you to the foot way at Dustin Road so
it's possible to go from the site to
Dustin Road on foot ways and we did have
a pre-application meeting with Highways
offices where they made this request and
I'm asked us to design this and that is
what we've carried out as part of this
application so I'm confident but they're
aware of this and they're they're happy
with this thank you for that and so any
further questions on that no I think I
see councillor stringer will come in
with some clarification on that I'm not
entirely convinced from the photos we've
been shown that there is Thank You chair
all right thank you
councillor Humphreys no questions thank
you councillor gold
no questions thank you absolute Caston
thank you madam chairman I wonder if I
would be able to just ask a quick
question of the drainage I'm
representative he he's got there because
it is quite a crucial point to me now
got a bit of a bee in my bonnet about
this well what's your question and can
we just have a quick response thank you
needs to be clear I understand that yes
okay so um in the modeling of this flood
risk has the fact that that is that suds
is located adjacent to a floodplain
being taken into considerate
consideration with the modeling
considering that is loma clay soil with
impeded drainage in the first place and
that should be a quick answer really yes
or no who's the expert on this respond
how's the drainage engineer so yes it's
the basin will be located in flood zone
1 so it is outside of the problem ok but
will that impede its operation if if it
is in a flood zone and it's flooded
because it is so it is outside the flood
zone the basin is outside the prosper
right okay on the edge of it but outside
of it and how far is it away could I
just ask it would be right on the edge
of it so it sits on the edge of flood
zone 1 but it is outside so it's outside
the one in a hundred year flood plain
right that's answered your question for
you to consider now then if you would
yeah okay so I don't have any questions
all the questions are being asked so I
now come to councillors stringer and if
you would like to tell us about this
application Thank You Francis drink mr.
barker can just delete his video that
would be super
thank you thank you yeah yeah all along
Mendel's from the sought to deliver all
that mid Suffolk and the government has
asked for in terms of housing delivery
and to date Mendelssohn has more than
delivered on all requirements from every
single policymaker it has in just over
three years into its first neighborhood
plan in mid Suffolk exceeded its
requirement not just for housing
approvals but completions we've
delivered these sensors on the face of
it agreeing with today's report looks at
first glance quite a simple step however
in more than one significant area our
officers have not taken into account
major policy areas that the Secretary of
State and countless appeal and
inspections have ruled upon that is the
impact of a development on an emerging
neighborhood plan and the successful
delivery of houses they're both material
considerations and they are and they
certainly haven't been addressed within
the documentation Mendelssohn has for
three years now been working on its
allocations of policy to update their
neighborhood plan and make it compliant
with the joint local plan emerging
toward local plan and further government
pronouncements so after results of many
public consultations and countless
reports based on expert evidence
published their allocations policy which
is in line with their submissions to the
joint local plan and in line with with
local feelings but despite requests the
content of this published emerging
neighborhood plan policy has not been
put in front of you the decision makers
which is deeply disappointing hours of
work by paid consultants volunteers and
public consultations forming a consensus
as to where the future of Housing and
Development should be has been basically
ignored so how do we how do we square
this circle because we have a number of
policies to balance here and we need to
bring them into balance after all we
have a village here like many others is
just trying to use their resources to
put the demand for development in the
right place so it one can be delivered
and to have the least impact on our
ability to keep delivering sufficient
homes into the future government
inspectors and the sacred state actually
do help us
here I've been having a look through
where there have been other decisions
appeal and secretary of state level
where there have been emerging
neighborhood plans this is pre
referendum this isn't just an amendment
to a neighbor plan this is a whole
emerging neighborhood plan and actually
the findings from the Secretary of State
and the penis figures is quite clear at
Wellingborough council the secretary
state ruled that proposals would
undermine the intentions of a
neighborhood plan and the Secretary of
State gave greater weight than that of
his inspector to an emerging plan and
dismissed the appeal broughton Ashley an
inspector allowed a development 111
homes but the second district quashed
the decision overruling the inspectors
decision stating that significant weight
we applied to it conflicting with the
emerging pre referendum neighborhood
plan Rendlesham here in Suffolk
inspector ruled that proposals conflict
with emerging neighborhood plans and
significantly undermine their objectives
and ruled ruled it be dismissed
Wiltshire Council refused 77 homes the
Secretary of State refused the
application despite there being a lack
of five-year land supply and stating the
community had completed a site selection
process which members room has done and
the immediate benefit of releasing the
land is insufficient to justify the
release of this site so soon before the
examination of the neighborhood plan is
carried out chess here in Chester the
inspector identified that emerging plans
do demonstrate how sufficient housing
could be provided and the Secretary of
State agreed with his inspector and
refused the appeal in membership they
have strong precisely how and where we
can deliver more than the houses
required in our neighborhood plan and
our joint local plan but not if this
application gains approval your officers
will suggest that no policy reason
exists for refusal yet
case after case supports the views of
local residents their neighborhood plan
team professional consultants and the
secretary States very clear that damage
to an emerging neighborhood plan is
sufficient to uphold a refusal at appeal
and even judicial review I would ask if
you wish to save this
local neighborhood plan you must refuse
this application Thank You chair Thank
You councillor stringer does anyone have
any question just for counselor stringer
council war boys no no questions thank
you can answer the Norris no questions
thank you that's the melon buy questions
Thank You chair councillor Humphreys yes
mum Jody thank you and and I need some
clarity as to do which I'm hoping it sir
mr. Paine to attempt in and help you
keep going on about the emerging local
plan but the significant way is
obviously given to the adopted
neighbourhood plan and I do understand
that you do have an emerging revision of
that local plan and that has some weight
but not as much way as an adopted one
for clarity for all the members present
and for the people of the public I would
like mr. Peyton Qi if it's possible
chair to actually show the difference
between the current adopted
neighbourhood plan that has significant
weight and a revision to see if there is
any effect on this actual development
plan and well I hear what you say that
wasn't exactly a question to councilor
stringers so the question was that you
must agree that that the adopted
neighbourhood plan has significant
weight and more waiting in an emerging
plan that's a fact and I had a question
which I think you'll agree with okay if
you don't I'd still watch some clarity
because the the ward members stood up
and spoke about the emerging plan how
important it is and yet we've not seen
it for you to be able to see all that
documentation I have baked our officers
to put that in front of you it has
already published its public domain I've
begged them to give you that
documentation because you are the
decision-maker and as far as I'm
concerned I think you need that
information so you can balance the
judgment yourself the Secretary of State
has done it before yeah hang on that
goes finger but what I would say is we
do
put neighborhood plans before every
planning application I'm afraid and that
and that is a fact we don't they are
available and I hear your passion and I
want to hear the debate going forward
and taking on all your views so
councillor Humphries I hear your point
and we will come to that but I think you
did put it to a question and councillors
trigger disagreed with your thoughts on
that councillor gold thank you no
questions I'm sure Thank You councillor
Caston no questions madam chair and I
don't have any questions on that but I
think it is a good point to bring in
John patron G to explain to us what's
going on with the neighbourhood plan and
his his interpretation of that so that
we can listen and see what's what
thank you thank you
I will admit because this is going to
sound like I'm reading this and I am
reading this because I did take some
thought about this to write it down so I
do want to do my normal thing and try
and go all over the place so I am going
to be emitting upfront that I've written
this all down and I'm going to read this
to you to make sure that I am clear
concise and you know if there is any
challenge in the future that this is
very clear so let's look at the name of
the plan and policy the current
neighborhood plan policy has significant
weight it is part of your development
plan the same with local plan 1998 for
strategy focus review the policy MP one
of the neighbourhood plan sets out the
name of the plans housing policy in
summary it provides and I don't I
believe we might have some slides with
this on but I'll leave then we can we
can get the slides up please sorry to
interrupt
only though with Alex what I'm talking
it provides a minimum total of 75 houses
by being minimal this is not a
there is nothing in the policy to
prevent housing in excess of 75 and has
been talked about earlier more houses
have been developed in Mendoza than the
75 secondly it provides that any
significant figure increase significant
is not defined to this housing figure
will need to demonstrate that existing
local services will be able to cope or
appropriate measures by condition or
legal agreement and so on will be
provided on this basis we consider that
the proposal before us if it's
considered significant there was no
objection in this regard conditions have
been recommended and SIL is also in
place the policy also goes on to say
that support shall be given within the
settlement boundary for new development
that he doesn't provide an opposite for
outside the boundary and goes on to
provide that outside the settlement
boundary that individual proposals that
are immediately adjacent to the boundary
to develop small sites of sustainable
new homes will be supported the
reference of small sites is indicated
within the policy as 20 dwellings or
less this would be the case for this
proposal it wasn't the case for the
previous proposal which was more than 20
dwellings and that is why that was
refused even a small-scale development
not within or jacent the settlement
battery now this one actually is
adjacent to the southern boundary but
even those not within or adjacent to the
southern boundary is also supported as
long as it fulfills the sustainability
criteria or also within the
neighbourhood plan so on the basis of
the current neighborhood plan the
proposal is not in conflict with either
with the current neighbourhood plan
policy in terms of the principle of
housing development and we apply
significant weight to this however
Menahem is revising its neighborhood
plans the revision is not yet an
examination stage and officers within
your papers have applied little or
essentially limited weight to this
document it is appreciated that the
judgment of wait may not be agreed by
everybody men
May and have the opportunity and ability
to do so may wish to apply more weight
as it's their discretion to make that
judgment this is their judgment and it's
something that we judge I suspect in the
debate and consideration of the proposal
before them I would not however ever
recommend setting the revised
neighborhood plan aside as no wait it is
a material consideration officers have
applied the application of limited
weight as this would be in line with the
relevant stage of neighborhood plan as a
new neighborhood plan document this
revision is essentially that a new
neighborhood plan to replace a comment
one however it may be considered to have
more weight significant weight because
of the current neighborhood plan being
in place and is seen as just an
amendment again this is judgment as
officers we do not feel we have
sufficient evidence to test this so our
logical position would be compare it to
the current established neighborhood
plan stages as set out in the various
legislation however best to consider
both positions a revised neighborhood
plan would limited weight or one that
has significant weight given the debate
or given the questions so far
I might go as far to encourage members
to consider the revised neighborhood
plan as significant
what's important is what this means for
this development even if the
neighborhood plan revised neighborhood
plan was given significant weight in
this instance I would put to you that he
would not change the recommendation of
officers before you and I will explain
why the revised now if you could on the
slides change it to the revision if you
have that available please thank you the
revised neighborhood plan contains
allocations that did not feature before
and some changes to policy mp1 so let's
look at the revision before us this time
the mp1 provides a minimum total
161 dwellings instead of 75 new homes it
is still a minimum this is not a cap
there was nothing in the policy to
prevent housing in excess of 161
dwellings as before it provides there
any significant figure increase again
significant is not defined terre housing
figures would need to demonstrate that
existing local services will be able to
cope or appropriate measures will be
provided and on the basis of the
proposal before us your offices consider
but there is no objection in this regard
and conditions have been recommended
sill remains in place the policy also
says the same as it did before
in terms of the location of development
outside the settlement boundary would
references small sites within the policy
again as 20 dwellings regardless of
allegation this allowance remains the
same nothing has changed in the new
policy except for the minimum number of
dwellings and so this revised
neighborhood plan is not in our opinion
in any conflict with a principle of
housing of the proposal with for us
today if it's given limited weight or
significant weight lastly there's a
couple of things I do you want to
mention regarding the NP a name her plan
there may be a consideration that the
wording despite my explanation does mean
that there is a cap on development 161
given the allocations put forward if
members consider this to be the case I
would immediately advise members that
the revised neighborhood plan should be
given limited weight because it would be
in clear conflict with the NPP f and in
terms of it the MPP F have eyes you
should not put a cap on development it
would be regarded as a now to date
document immediately and I appreciate
the word out to date is a bit odd and
helpful but it effectively means it
would be given less weight
members will be aware that the mid
Suffolk Local Plan and associated
documents are to this day not given for
weight because of their current
conflicts with the NPP f and this is why
the Mustafa Qadri Council cannot engage
its own settlement boundary policy to
the full extent at this time and it
hoped that the new joint local plan will
eventually resolve that point as for the
new local joint Local Plan members
should consider the current published
edition as having limited weight and it
is appreciated that this is an evolving
document but intelligence close to his
own examination stage they should
continue to have limited weight now I
appreciate I've gone on for a bit but
there are a number of views and
interpretations involved and I've
considered it to be necessary to say
this for the record
officers have considered the current and
revised they were plan and all
associated doctrines we have provided
our members with consideration of weight
that members may take their own
judgement to apply more or less but this
is the application of weights of the
policy is not considered to alter the
wording of the policy and the
development is not considered to be in
conflict regardless of weight and on
that point I will leave it and I hope
that serves thank you thank you indeed
for that that was very helpful so we now
are open for debate and while we are
debating this item can we look we will
obviously be include all that we've
heard thus far but if we can look at the
application as a whole as to what
exactly is before us so I'll open it up
for debate and I will go round in
reverse order again so that we have
different outlets to start with and may
I ask council of war boys please thank
you and what I would do if I may is can
I suggest that once we've all had a say
if there is anybody that wants to put a
proposal forward please use the hands up
signal to just indicate that you want to
put a proposal forward and we
in that basis okay so counselor wall
boys thank you thank you very much chair
yes I do appreciate that a great deal of
thought has been put into the proposal
before us in terms of landscaping the
energy efficiency of the houses however
this is a very sensitive site I think on
the approach to the village and we have
had comments from Mendelssohn from the
parish council regarding how this site
does affect access to the village and
the suspect and the expected increases
in traffic I am there's two concerns
I've got it really it's about
deliverability of this footpath I have
had a quick look through the website
I've got two assertions here one is from
the developer that this is deliverable
and that Suffolk County Council have
actually got a definite definitive
proposal however this is in conflict
with what the Parish Council says and as
I don't got access to a drawing I can't
really comment on whether this the
Parish Council is is right in this so my
feeling is that I go with what the
approach Council says in case in sense
that though this development is close as
the crow flies it's not necessarily that
easy to access and it's not that
sustainable there is in both the adopted
local plan and the revised local plan
questions that the any proposed
development should satisfy sustainable
criteria I think the Parish Council is
of the opinion that
this doesn't I think there is conflict
with the emerging local plan and a
community does has put forward very
significant proposals for development
it's not against development but it does
want to control that development have
the development where is best for the
village where it does actually support
that village as a sustainable community
so my feeling needs to go to give more
weight to this in the revised
neighbourhood plan thank you thank you
to that council at war boys may we hear
from councillor Norris thank you madam
chairman well I think council war boys
has put into words a lot of my feelings
on this application
Overton Parish Council about their
consideration of a site adjacent to
glebe way as being more preferable I'm
also a little bit unconvinced regarding
the footpath link we've heard from the
ward member which still necessarily
cross the road etc and perhaps the
emerging revision of the neighbourhood
plan should have green prevented
presented sorry presented to us within
the papers actually originally and help
us to understand T oh I do have some
concerns on this application which
really have not been fully met thank you
thank you that um councillor melon yes
thank you chair um when I was looking at
the documents yesterday and reading
through this yeah I think there's a lot
to commend this application and the
sustainability measures that the
applicant had proposed are to be
welcomed the reduction in number of the
houses from 49 of the previous
application to 20 and the provision of
green spaces to be welcomed and the
retention and better connections into
the footpath network seems to be good as
well but it's when you start digging
into it that there seems to be one or
two problems I do share concerns
expressed by the two previous
councillors about the footpath link I
from what I can see there's a footpath
link to be provided to the frontage of
my field way and after that you've got
to sort of negotiate crossing to a verge
and that sort of thing
now the existing users of Mayfield way
have the same problem so that's no sort
of particular detriment but I guess what
overall we're saying is there's a
provision of an upgraded footpath but
it's not exactly what we would want it's
not the connectivity that I believe the
county councillors requested and then
the other point to come so is the is
mineral shims engagement with the local
prime or the neighbourhood planned
process I mean it seems to me that men
do some have done everything they
possibly can to you know their spent
time and money and really as a community
there are kind of an exemplar of of what
all communities should be doing in terms
of trying to plan their development and
engage with the planning process and
having sort of acknowledged that and
then having heard John Paton Gees
explanation
I do feel fairly uncomfortable about the
possibility of sort of a going against
the the work that the neighbourhood plan
group have done particularly where they
haven't shied away from allocating sites
so that that's a little bit of a problem
for me and that's where I'm at the
moment thank you Jeff thank you for that
councillor Mellon and Alex do you think
you could put up some more mine you
shared detail of a footpath that we
might have yes I certainly tried sure
I don't think it was particularly in
your presentation was it well is that do
we have anything better that's that's as
part of the proposal in terms of so you
can okay yeah I speak about if I may
come in the biggest problem with this
plan is it doesn't actually show where
ducks and Road is which is just off the
plan
so is there do we have anything that
just goes a bit further to show where
the starter dachshund Road is in
association with this development yeah
would it be permissible to stick another
plan on if I was to share one in terms
of I can take a google aerial view and I
think it would be helpful to members to
look at the distances involved well
we're not trying to hide anything here
and the board member has explained the
difficulties of it and the the speakers
so far have been trying to tussle with
it you can hear they are if that is a
useful plan then I don't see that
there's any objection to it going
forward to look at it
but in parts of the presentation thus
far no I appreciate that I apologize for
that
if I may take a leave and just share the
current Google aerial view if I can just
show members that just point out on me
are you okay oh if I carry on with that
yes yes and you know it might help them
everybody who's speaking on this and
who's already spoken and I apologize to
the others that are waiting I just want
to do it be useful to show this I take
it this all on every screen the
application site ultimately is here
which is the the field
this is Mayfield way what we're talking
about is the linkage across here
Mayfield way already has a footpath at
this point and coming across and we're
talking about that's the short gap
in order to get two ducks in road I just
think without seeing where the road is
it's very difficult to have the debate
in its fall so that is the route we are
essentially talking about the respect of
the improvement works and so on as they
go through because I'm sure we'll come
back to other members again for further
discussion so I think that would be
useful to leave that there for the
moment
Thank You councillor Humphries I'm sure
thank you that's like so it's really
refreshing actually to see that only
thirteen point six dwellings being
planned per hectare as we know in policy
cs9 it allows it to 30 so that's a
really good thing especially in a rural
village like this fits them really
nicely also the location of this
development
I was looking from space it seems the
ideal point but the current the current
residential area fits in there quite
nicely and the use of solar panels
grants or seating electrical charging
points also very welcomed our
environmental challenge goes forward so
that's all good stuff so far it's also
refreshing to see as evidenced by the
offices presentation and some of the
debate discussion and questions that
we've had so far that most of the
previous reasons in fact I would say all
of the previous reasons for refusal have
been addressed especially significantly
is the reduction from 49 to 20 well ins
which is really welcomed that reduction
in dwelling numbers fits in with the
adopted neighbourhood plan and also the
emerging neighbourhood plan so that's
good because it fits in with a policy
that's been written by the resident
stroke the parish council excellent one
of the read through summary of
objections all the points raised I
believe been satisfied body develop belt
or ever agencies including flood so
we'll go to the flood because that's
come up a few times are just a bit of a
correction really it was comment MP fall
at flood zone one was a warning 100-year
event I believe it's a warning 1000 yeah
so just underline that there and also
that development as long as it's under a
hectare actually is
is allowed and if you look at all the
maps and all the charts
we are outside of any risk of flood
we've Flint's own one so the chances
minimum we still host we can get apart
from zero so I think the flooding issue
it's taking us down a route when
actually if you look through all the
papers and you look at the maps and you
understand the flood zone categories I
believe it's a little to no risk there's
always a risk but it's Lily to know in
this case
it's therefore it's not an a massive
factor for this particular development
[Music]
you could say that actually this
development is in line with the wishes
that the residents if you believe that
the adopted neighborhood plan is the
wishes of the of the residents and also
the the parish council and therefore it
is you know they've said they yeah we
don't mind any development that buts our
settlement boundary as long as it's 20
dwellings unless Melisa fits in with
that and satisfies all the requirements
well I think it does on sustainability
actually but if we go down to the
footpath issue and the fact that on page
wherever the map is the map does showed
that actually the footpath between
Mayfield Way and the developments going
to be developed and as John Paton chase
said there is a small footpath there and
you do have to cross the road well you
can't have a continuous footpath this is
the road in a way so a little bit common
sense comes into this as well at some
point we will have to cross the road and
we'll try and minimize that I'm sure as
much as possible and fortunately there
is a house between Mayfield Way and
Dunston Road on a North Sider Chapel
Road that might prevent some of that
development so no matter what we what we
want there is a very good chance that we
can't have everything we want and I
think that compromise is that it'll go
as far as possible and we'll have to
cross the road that's modern life in a
village town or any other development
when it comes down to it I've been read
through all of this and listen to all
the the arguments and the questions and
some of the debates I believe there are
no planning reasons legal reasons why we
should not approve this application
it complies completely I believe with
the adopted Mendelssohn neighborhood
plan that has significant weights and it
also complies with the emerging revised
version of neighborhood plan that well
said it's got limited weight but even it
had all the weight in the world it
complies with it so it complies with
both elements of the native neighborhood
plan in respect to the amount of
development that can go on in that
location in my opinion I think that's
pretty much it yeah I I just can't see a
reason not to breathe this on minded to
go for approval to be honest
thank you we're not looking for that at
the moment but I hear your points of
view Thank You Candice yeah councillor
gold thank you madam chair but first on
the neighborhood plan issues and I'm
grateful to mr. Peyton G for his
comments and advice in relation to that
which just goes to show that this is not
a a simple matter
and I'm concerned that the report at
page 20 and I've seen it another other
telling reports as well
appears to equate a particular stage of
the neighborhood planning process with
mechanically with a level of
significance so so we've got in the
report it says that the revised
neighborhood plan currently at stage 1
and accordingly has at the current time
little weight well I think it's mr.
payment G is demonstrated it's not as
simple as that and so I'd like to ask
that in other planning of future
planning reports that we we deal with
the with the complexity of the
significance of neighborhood plans
I think our Menon who talked about the
mental Sims plan isn't as an exemplar
and
I don't disagree with him certainly went
in the early stages of the preparation
of the Eyre neighborhood plant we found
there was much to learn from the way
that member shim had collaborated
certainly as one of the early developers
of a neighborhood plan and particularly
in terms of community engagement and and
so on but one of the things that we
learned from the process is the
importance of having an allocations
policy and that with us in allocations
policy you need the allocation policy -
- to give effect to the name of the plan
and I recognize that that's where the
the the revised plan is at and it's it
was interesting here that they have a
site for 20 houses within within the
plan but we can only look at the
application that's before us and then I
come to the remarks that a number of
cancers have made which is that actually
there is a great deal of merit within
this within this application and
actually all the masses reasons for
refusal of the early application have
been addressed and therefore I see on
that basis no planning reasons really
for not supporting the application be
forced
thank you ma'am chin Thank You
councillor gold councillor Caston please
thank you very much madam chairman so I
am I just wanted to talk a little bit
more about this flooding situation I do
have concerns the risk of areum the
subsist
a few metres away from a flood claim one
in a thousand years it's um one in a
thousand years doesn't mean it's going
to be a thousand years until that level
of flooding it means next winter it
could flood to a thousand year levels
but the soul type is liable to be
seasonally wet I'm not an in a drainage
engineer but I have sat on the county's
flood risk scrutiny committee and the
drainage board for for several years now
but I can only work with the information
that's in front of me and that says it
does it accessible so I can't I can't go
against it I am concerned if there's a
mechanism that we could activate to make
sure that that drainage model is correct
I'd like to activate that but I can't
object to this application just on that
basis I like the mix of houses here
there's this useful houses for residents
for young people that have grown up at
Mendel Shimla's houses that they could
actually afford to buy the land I don't
think it's a great loss to of
agricultural land because from the
pictures I'd look at that OC rate crop
and I I can see that isn't the most
productive land in Suffolk the the
footpath is regrettable that it doesn't
go straight across but it does have a
nice open straight bit of Road it's not
on a bend I think if that was on a type
end they'd be a serious concern to me
but it's not a massive concern at the
moment so I think on that basis I would
I wouldn't object to this application
but I do understand the neighborhood
plan issues and the the conflicts and of
thought quite a lot about the the weight
that they carry at the moment I'm minded
for approval thank you madam chairman
thank you for that councillor Caston and
that now comes to me I've been listening
very carefully to everyone and I think
everyone is very
appreciative of all the hard work that's
gone into a neighborhood plan as I said
earlier it's not normal to get copies of
the neighborhood plan a place before us
emerging or otherwise and somebody
mentioned earlier that the JLP currently
isn't given full weight because it's not
been approved and I'm afraid that's why
it sits with the current Mendelssohn
plan that we can't give as much full
weight as maybe we would like to there's
think copious amounts of work gone in
there commenting about councilor customs
the last refusal on Sudz that there was
no refusal on subs for flooding but I'm
appreciative of his knowledge not only
as being on that committee but also as a
farmer and we all know what clay is like
and things like that so I welcomed his
improving inquiries into that aspect of
it I'm just hearing everybody talking
about the footpath and is there any
mileage that we can put that there's a
tacit agreement that it doesn't go ahead
should members be minded to approve it
until that footpath is fully explored
and satisfactory I just put that one as
we go around for a second debate so I
find it very difficult to find a
planning reason for refusal ish you
could say oh the neighborhood plan but
it isn't fully in place very difficult
situation and the passion of the ward
member and all the evidence that he's
supplied to us I'm very grateful for
because we do get these cases coming up
as we go forward so at the moment I
can't find anything to refuse it on so
that's where I'm at at the moment so
I wonder if we would like to go round
again or if anyone has a proposal that
they want to put to me oh wait a minute
the legal person before councillor
Humphries yes sorry two countries and
just sort of put myself on camera just
through awareness I think I've managed
just the same madam chairman I have had
a message just gone only to me quite
properly by from councillor to me as
legal advisors and counselors ringer we
do now we obviously councillor stringers
positioners ward member here is he's
normally a member the committee that we
follow our mid Suffolk rule that if we
were in the council chamber he'd be
sitting apart he has the right to speak
as he would have if he were not not a
member of the committee and regular
members of committee but he then doesn't
participate in the debate however I'm
just mindful councillor stringer has
said to me he hasn't enough unanswered
question I think I'm mindful of the fact
that we had what I think I found I know
members have said they found a very
useful and detailed piece of advice on
the weights of policies but including
the name of the plan policies that was
something the the officers comments was
something that in it on a different
chain of events might have come earlier
but because they came late I'm very much
mindful we must follow our usual rules
and not allow counsel stringer to
participate in the debate but I do feel
I should advise you that we should be
departing little and just if we may go
to councillor stringer and to see what
what you have can we assist him further
on answering questions without without
in participating in the debate so if you
if we made madam chairman that's my
advice thank you for that
and if councillor Humphreys can just
wait for one moment and because we are
in unusual situations where are you
councillor string and do please yes wish
to stay in a situation in normal
circumstances this wouldn't be happening
but we're not in normal circumstances
given what I've just heard there's an
unanswered question my third question
from earlier it was always pivotal it
has not been answered and in fact has
actually got more muddied we've had
members now and officers quoting from
the front page of the emerging
neighborhood plan without showing you
its allocations maps which is not
helpful but my initial question was have
you taken into account the impact of
approving this application on the
published amendment to the neighborhood
plan that is what all of those appeal
inspections and ruled upon it's not
what's policy on what isn't policy it's
the impact of your actions that is what
I asked the question of and that is what
I have had not the answer to I've had
the answer from all the appeal rulings I
haven't had the I need to make sure that
the decision makers nugu councillors
have recognized the impact you will have
on that emerging neighborhood plan on
your decision and if you haven't seen
all of it that is somewhat difficult the
other small point is the officers keep
relating to talking about a footpath
from a fee away
that is not the foot path that everybody
uses there is two footpaths that link
mouths away and not one person has shown
you LA's which is deeply regretful but
it but it if you if you want to go with
what you've got that's fine but there is
it's that unanswered question which is
why you're grappling Council Humphrey
said that he was happy that the new
emerging neighborhood plan was
consistent because he'd read the front
page he hadn't read all of the
documentation which actually said the
front page is the policy but it has to
be linked to those proposals Maps
to make this deliverable Thank You Jay I
think you can just go back to the
footpath issue can somebody if I may yes
[Music]
so I council finger that that question
at the point that question should have
been asked was a question to officers if
I am correct correct
we you know as officers you would have
seen the the officer report and I am
completely satisfied that the officer
has read the documentation in full and
taken that into account I appreciate
that this decision would have in an
impact on the rest of the revised
neighborhood plan but I'm also equally
considerate of the actual policy wording
of the revised neighborhood plan and
regardless of allocation that policy in
the way it is worded allows for
development outside the settlement
boundary and it indicates 20 well and I
also have a bearing on this that comes
from the previous refusal because of how
the previous refusal which is also a
material consideration now admittedly
the previous refusal was in respect of
the current neighborhood plan but I'm
I'm happy that looking at all of the
evidence in the round of my explanation
to members but I agree it is very
complicated and it is all a matter of
judgment of wait but it I can't do
anything more than I've done ultimately
it is now for members just consider the
weight that they apply but I do not
believe in the way we have interpreted
the policy but there is a prevention of
housing before us and that up to 20 is
an indication within that policy outside
the boundary that can be allowed for
thank you thank you right so I think
we've we've come to the next applicant
or a person would be councillor
Humphries you wish to speak thank you
I'm chair thank you yes go back to
councillor stringers point I've read
obviously the old policy that we we've
seen regarding the as mr. payment ye
said about building and have being
allowed to develop 2012 saw less on our
sites but in the settlement all our sand
was that
I also read because it's been shown on
this top on this presentation the
emerging plan and that I can't see any
difference in that strict policy element
that we've seen and I can only base my
opinion and my comments and what I see
and what I read in this in this proposal
and that's all of them
the wait for proposals now that's why I
raised my hand so yeah have you listened
to everybody and their hats off to
Mendel Shem and and you're right back
the neighborhood plan a lot of works
been going on within it before run now
and it's refreshing to see actually that
a local parish council not only makes
the development plan and publishes it
but they revisit it they amend it and
they update it and that's quite rare and
you should be congratulating for it but
having said that having read that policy
statement on page one there is no change
that affects this actual development and
for that you know I do I can't find any
legal or planning reason why we can't
agree to approve this this
recommendation and therefore I am moving
a recommendation for approval thank you
for that councillor Humphreys do I have
a seconder to that proposal please madam
chair James Catherine wood would like to
second that I think this is a really
difficult application it's very
complicated I think the benefits
outweigh the issues with this so I'd
like to second that proposal thank you
for that I will go around again to let
other people talk if I may please
so councillor war boys do you wish to
say anything else yes I don't think I'm
prepared to accept to to support this
proposal at this stage I feel we've
we've had a great deal of discussion and
if we actually supported the proposal
we would actually be basically owned
using our opinions of what is good or a
benefit for Mendel Shem
I think Mendel Shem parish council has
gone to a great deal of effort to
propose their neighbor plan and a
revised neighbor plan looking at the
community as a whole and and we're we
are restricted to look at what's within
the the red the red lines but on the
other hand the the weight that we need
to attach to the neighborhood plan and
the revised neighborhood plan is based
on looking at the community hall and
they have got very objective arguments
you have taken professional advice they
have consulted with the communities they
are representing their communities and
they had a definitive idea of how they
want the community to develop and I
think we should support that process hi
the concept of the impact of our
decision on those processes and other
processes within which suffer is is very
very important and I think and I think
we do need to bear that in mind that we
don't give too much weight to our
opinions on what is good for Mendel Shem
but we should really look at Mendel Shem
parish councils objective arguments here
about what is good for their community
thank you for that counselor wall boys
and councillor Norris would you like to
say anything again please yes thank you
I tend to follow council Baba's
arguments regarding the amount of work
and time obviously and some considerable
financial cost on Shaw has been incurred
in producing a neighborhood plan by the
residents and the parish council and
also now working on this revision that's
coming forward on the neighborhood plan
we I think we should respect
their knowledge of their own area I have
indicated a preference actually for an
alternative site I also still have some
issues with connectivity and I want to
keep laboring the point on this book
path but to me the simple solution would
be to have a crossing point somewhere on
Chapel Road actually but perhaps that's
a different matter
so I still are still not fully able to
support this application thank you thank
you for that counselor nice castle wall
boys can you take your video off with a
minute please if you would councillor
Mellon if you would please further
comment yes thank you chair um I think
this three just very brief comments once
I make one is I've had a look on Google
Street View of the the footpath issue
and the crossing across the ducts and
Road and and I think to be honest my my
concerns there are largely a lot need I
think there is the potential for a
connection there which I think the the
parish council could achieve at some
point in the future if they put their
minds to it the second thing is the
flooding
I think the floods advisor to the
applicant said that this is in
floodplain one and it looks to me it's
on the edge of flood plain too so that
does raise it up a little bit higher in
my concerns than perhaps it was before
we are seeing these one in a thousand
years ents turning up with more more
sort of frequent regularity across the
world with with climate change so that
is a concern but my main concern is this
issue of the the the neighborhood plan
and where we stand with that and I'm
very grateful to John Paton gee for his
very careful explanation of the
legalities there but overall I just feel
uncomfortable with going against the
work that neighborhood team in Menasha
have done
it does really leave me to feel that I
will vote against the proposal thank you
thank you for that councillor Humphreys
do you want to say anything else at all
so much I haven't but I have problems
pressing the microphone noblest or I
think that counts the war boys your
points absolutely valid and nobody's
taking it away from the the local parish
council as I said in my in my proposal
they should be congratulating really for
the work they do on behalf of the
residents and the fact they do re re
it's at the neighbourhood plan improve
it for the future and evolve it and that
that's fantastic however we can only go
on what's in front of us and the
emerging local plan on that policy
statement as I said before is still in
line with what's written in the current
adopted neighbourhood plan it's less
than it's 20 or less dwellings that's
accepted as acceptable by to parish and
all the reasons for the refusal they've
been addressed I just don't understand
why we couldn't prove this legally
there's no planning reason why we can't
prove it
Thank You councillor Gould any further
comments no no further comment for me
cancer Caston any further comments no
further comments madam chair thank you
very much then I have a proposer in a
second or so I go to the chief planning
the planning officer and area planning
manager to read out the proposal that we
have before us before we go to the vote
please I am not aware of any additions
to the recommendation before you in
terms of the papers so rather than just
list all the conditions that are in
there I can only perhaps just say that
the recommendation is one of approval as
per your papers and I'm about to say
which page that is not a good page thank
you very much the unfortunate I don't
have a paper copy of trying to get you
to be electronic still my basis so in
respect of that but like I said there
was no additional conditions that were
being discussed there was a part mention
about that the layout to be in general
accord with the indicative plan but that
hasn't my knowledge been added to the
recommendation so the recommendation is
just as it is presented thank you it's
the proposer and second are happy with
the proposals madam chairman I did him I
didn't mention earlier whether there was
a weighty one double-check the the
modeling on that flood risk before I'm
approval just like to ask the officer if
that's possible if I may
obviously we have the County Council as
the flood authority who are essentially
the second check so we you know at this
stage they see no concern to put forward
to us they would be involved later as
well those required by the local lead
flood authority as recommended so it is
in there it's in there
so we've already put that forward in in
place and I just lastly just to point
out that what we have in forest is an
indicative plan and if and there's a lot
of space around the attenuation Basin
and a lot of space around the houses so
there's a lot of flexibility there
absolutely necessary to move that
location slightly as required when it
comes to as a matter stage and that
would be dealt with accordingly
thank you rightfully not to the top of
the hill sorry I didn't catch that well
I just the attenuation basins got to be
at the bottom of the hill surely I don't
think that we've got if not vote against
it just to clarify my mistake and if you
we needed to move it slightly away from
the boundary by it by a meet or two you
know that that's within the remit of
that indicative clad houses yes sorry my
apologies I see where you're coming from
yeah okay so can I move to Robert please
to take the appropriate vote thank you
Thank You chair so if you could please
respond with for against or abstain so
councillor James Carson for councillor
Peter Gould for councillor Cathy Guthrie
for councillor Barry Humphries for
councillor Andrew Mellon against
councillor Mike Norris engaged and
councillor Rowland war boys against
thank your chair that is carried and yes
chairman this is this is the legal
adviser agreeing I groups to Carmichael
is indeed carried I counted with him
that's four three isn't it right can we
have a comfort break for 15 minutes
please and then be back to do the second
application if we would I would suggest
everybody well I'm certainly going to
leave my machine available for use and
thank you to all the people that have
joined in on the meeting if you could
now leave the meeting who won't be
required for the next part of the debate
thank you very much
you
Thank You chef I'll now just take
another roll call to confirm all members
are here for the second item of the day
I haven't got my camera on apologies
rude of me
so counselor so casa james Karsten
present counselor Peter Gould present
counselor cursory present counsel
Humphreys prisons counselor melon
president councillor Norris present
house a stringer present counselor war
boys present and could I just please
confirm that our two public speakers are
here of mr. Steven Hubner mr. Steven
happiness front Parish Council yes thank
you thank you sir and then also mr.
Sebastian blemings yes
take your chair we are all here right
and I hope we've got Sarah Scott to
introduce the case so if we move on now
to the application DC 20mm two six three
land a trio of cedar cottage to the
street Rockhold Suffolk so Sarah Scott
if you'd like to introduce the
application please thank you very much
unfortunately service port is not
available today for unforeseen
circumstances so you will be presented
this by myself
okay and in that case John pain and G
will sent the case then thank you very
much thank you so this is application DC
strike 22 six free land to the rear of
cedar cottage there's a full application
for the erection of one two-story
dwelling wood attached garage
and the location of the village of our
cult is between Debenham and I
essentially it has a farmer school
village hall and other services closer
in the site is within the west side of
the village just in this point here
we'll look at that closely in a minute
and this is the ventline village the
closer in we can see that this is the
site we're talking about I'll come up
with a red line at a moment this is the
B 107 7 running on one side and we have
Church Street on the other see the
cottage is the dwelling existing
dwelling not part of the site to the
north and we also see on this
unfortunate is the most up-to-date
aerial photograph we can get hold of at
the moment we can see that there is
construction of dwellings adjacent and
this is a previous approval there are 8
dwellings and they they are being built
now they are in a more advanced state of
construction which on-site photos taken
at the end of last week will show in a
moment so just to reiterate the red line
planned for this site is as shown and we
have a blue line plan as well with
regard to the adjacent site that is in
the middle of construction
Caeser cottage is the property first
here the access to the red line plan is
via the existing or new access that now
that has been built as part of this
development constraints map just to show
that there are no immediate planning
considerations or constraint in terms of
the site itself we have the settlement
boundary which is this line as shown
here the brown line and
this development is outside of that
settlement boundary so here we have the
layout plan the proposal of the proposed
dwelling is set adjacent to the last
plot almost built next door so this is
the new proposed dwelling single
dwelling against the current ones being
built and you will see that the that is
the garage attached garage as part of
the proposal and it's in line with
listen to the garage of cedars cottage
which is settled on the road frontage at
Church Street can I just clarify can
able to see my cursor okay it looks very
small to me as I'm pointing things out
is that okay I take it that it is my
screen so the design is arm themed
contemporary barn themed as a two-story
dwelling it's eight point seven meters
high with eaves five meters the style is
in line with the contemporary approach
of the new adjacent development being
built at the moment and the garage part
which is this element here this element
here is the closer to the north and
closer to cedar cottage it block so we
have a bedroom window on the side of
course it the garage itself blocks out
any view form that window over towards
Cedar cottage for the most part you
might just see the end of the cedar
cottage garage from there but you
wouldn't see the majority of the garden
or the house and we have first floor at
the rear we have first floor roof lights
these obviously will overlook the new
rear garden so if I just go back here
the roof lights overlooking the rear
garden there will be no direct over or
King but I'm not going to say there
wouldn't be any overlooking as if you
stand very close to the roof light and
purposely look at an angle you possibly
can look at 45-degree angles
so those are those roof like windows but
in all other respects the building is
designed to block out any intrusive
overlooking view just for the sake of
clarity this is the floor plan
again this is the garage this is the the
various layers the bedrooms and so forth
so you have a bedroom window at first
floor at the side and we have the roof
lights they go down the first set just
go down to the kitchen is the and then
you have the second set that go into the
bedroom bathroom and ensuite
this is cedar cottage taken from the
site the first thing you will notice is
the roof appears to come out to the
ground that is because cedar cottage is
a traditional cottage a non designated
historic asset that fronts the main road
and is set lower than the land that
forms part of this application site it's
a good couple of metres and I think
probably looking at the eaves height and
the car is a good indication of where
the land sits in an association so I'm
just going to run through these
photographs just to say these have been
taken fairly recently from site itself
and you will see that the adjacent
development is in full swing of nearing
completion in terms of the linear line
of houses that have been created there
and I'll go back to show you where that
is in correspondence with the site in a
moment
so these are the various outlooks from
the site and set me back in Cedars
cottage existing development on the
other side of the road and the site
itself this is the access to the new
site via the existing being built
constructed development adjacent
just to give you a general overview
again we're back to the last plot before
the new puzzle and just coming back
along the road further into the village
to look back we have the junction with
Church Street Road street with the b1o
77 and you see this cottage is hidden
away within the vegetation there and we
had the new development there's been
building on the street that's the new
access that's been built for the new
development which would lead into the
oppose single dwelling so we have Cedars
cottage just here and the site just for
you and again from the other angle the
cottage its garage and the site would be
behind that and our distance to you as
well so that's the employed as currently
built that's the cottage and the site is
essentially sitting in the middle there
now I just put this map photo on with
the layout on it at the same time just
to just give the indication of where
things are so the house on the other
side of the road is that property there
and that's the indication of that
property there and in the property it's
in line with that property that the new
proposal would be so we then have just
for reference the adjacent development
that's there now which is that one just
there and the new development would be
in front of that and
we know that that cedar Scottish in
terms of sustainable development this is
outside the settlement boundary but
would be very much part of the current
village and the adjacent a recently
approved scheme for eight willings this
would form a bookend to that development
in this location we have no access
issues given that approval had the
development been part of the adjacent
eight it would not have resulted in any
additional policy trigger for
infrastructure requirements and the
proposal does not seek to circumvent any
obligations on that in that regard the
dwelling will be subject to further sill
contribution looking at the site the
design and layout of the dwelling has
been considered to avoid any significant
overlooking and amenity issues by the
way of the types of windows and their
positions within the Dornan design
officers don't think this would be
sufficient as a issue on its own to
warrant refusal in the balanced levels
are significantly different between
cedar cottage and the PO site given the
layout orientation along the distance
and the opportunity to landscape there
is a judgment on overbearing and
dominance to consider and on balance is
considered - this is acceptable in this
case so the officer recommendation is
one of approval as per your papers thank
you thank you for that John um in our
briefing we had some photographs that
came from the actual corner looking
towards the cottage I wonder if you
could route that out for us please and
pop that up at some stage and and I do
have a question here sorry to jump in
against everyone else on the the slide
you've got on at the moment where the
house is there's potentially three trees
they're showing from the house but
there's a green line going to the back
of you can see a green line just going
to the back of the cottage and the long
what what is the gap between that green
line and the edge of the ownership of
cedar cottage and what is that likely to
be please
can you give me a moment to measure that
I'm gonna have to stop sharing come out
yeah thank you but if you can find that
that other photograph that we saw from
the corner and I think that would help
members as well thank you okay
so are you able John to take questions
as we continue yes I will definitely try
of course this is the peril of
presenting and doing this at the same
time but they do you have questions for
the presentation please thank you yeah I
think Alexa range of photographs I
thought especially as they showed the
the significant height difference
between the their land at the back of
the cottage and the the the road level
it's between two and three meters I
think I get the overall height of the
the proposed building as somewhere about
11 meters taken into account the
difference in ground levels would you
would you agree with that I wouldn't
disagree with that as a rough ballpark
yes yeah nobody can build it the
building proposes 8.6
yes or eight point seven meters
ryan ten so ten point seven to eleven
meters thank you oh sorry Thank You
councillor ball boys councillor stringer
yeah we're just doing questions
yeah just question can you tell me
whether this part of this site is inside
or outside the draft joint local plan
I can't I will check and come back to
you any other questions cancel the
stringer no thanks that's it councillor
Norris no questions are such thank you
Thank You councillor Mellon no questions
but I am looking at the the emerging
local plan map and it does not appear to
be inside the boundary there well
welcome to this day and that will be
very helpful thank you thank you yes
that is correct I've just found at the
same time you got there first it is now
this particular party's outside of that
line you're quite correct although the
adjacent eight are within the proposed
joint local plan boundary where are we
Humphreys no questions thank you and
we'll come to Peter gold later because
he's the ward member councillor caster
no questions thank you madam chairman
well actually I I did this the last time
and asked councillor stringer so council
ago do you have any questions for the
officer no I don't thank you thank you
thank you very much right so any nearer
to getting the the other photographs
general yeah one more moment I'm just
like quickly pulling them up now they're
with me
please out within a minute I'm not sure
we'll share this they're somewhere to
copy
it was just the two that you showed as
it required helpful France or yes and as
councillor Mellon said they were very
good photographs that you've supplied
now but it was just one angle that was
was seemingly missing
I believe thirty-one madam chairman know
it's hidden to slide actually no okay
bear with me I'll just go quickly go
through the the neighbor letters just to
find it and then we'll come to the
public speaker then if we may please we
have the parish council representative
Steven Huebner if you have three minutes
would you like to tell us about the
application site and the parish councils
views if you would please thank you
thank you sure it's very kind and yes
the the parish council objects to the
proposal and there are a number of
fundamental reasons one has been
highlighted to you already that the
location falls outside the proposed
joint Local Plan I think the reason for
that is fairly simple is because
permission was granted to what is now a
two dwellings within the confines or
what is shown by the blue line on the
plans you see not extending into this
particular area the rear of cedar
cottage so this would be taking the
development one step further outside the
settlement area the second issue we have
is to do with the mass inappropriate
massing of the proposed development
whilst I we can accept the principle of
bookending it's the existing eight
dwellings this property if built would
be at the different alignment to those
which exist of present and it would be a
dominating feature in the approach from
aisle on the B 1077 one of the photos
you saw showed that general layout of
the president of element from the I
direction it wasn't particularly clear
but if you imagine a very large bomb in
front of those existing dwellings though
be the appearance we would then see
and I'm afraid whilst the officer has
suggested that this property would not
dominate sida cottage
given the difference in land levels it
would completely obscure and overwhelm
any view of that property which is a
heritage will be in a listed building at
the entrance of the village the property
will also adversely affect the natural
flow of light to the properties on the
other side of the road which were in a
property called cedar close excuse me as
the officer pointed out such as the
location of the proposed development and
its height above the road last you would
wind up with something approximately 12
rather than 10 rubato 12 meters roofline
on the main angle through full light to
travel across the road to see this close
and I would have a significant and
material impact on the dwelling versus
the last issue we have is to do with the
impact of the garden to the rear of
Cedar cottage it's not clear on the
plans what is proposed there and I
accept the recommendation does include a
landscaping condition
you've asked but I'm sure exactly what
is proposed anyway and what the gap is
I'm interested many results but if you
imagine see the cottage will be
overlooked from the garden if not from
the dwelling itself and such as the
roofline there anybody standing the
proposed garden area would look directly
into the window to see the cottage that
is a pretty material intrusion on
privacy the issue is not that that could
not happen where the fields will be
farmland but of course that would only
happen farm man is farmland its
agricultural use it's not an amenity to
a dwelling I'm not like to be used for
the purpose of people standing outside
can you now finish your on to the or
three minutes if you would that is my
sweetness thank you I'm sure thank you
very much indeed
and just before um we come to questions
John can you just put that photograph up
and if you'll excuse us
mr. opener we'll just put the photograph
up for people to look at and then the
questions might answer themselves John
can you do that so coming through I
can't I can only show you through the
system so I can't bring that up on to
the PowerPoint Oh buddy that's clear so
can you just describe what we're looking
at here so this is the corner of the the
Main Street game for the village and the
b1o 77 at the top and this is taken from
the Cetus cottage the back office we've
had angles looking of course that way
that's the garage for the existing
property and that is the last plot being
built of the eight adjacent so that's
the land form there and you can see that
there's a couple of meters essentially
Wow good three meters in terms of that
line that oscillates around the
scientists and what what does that what
do those three meters who owns that what
does that tell us
I'm going back to the site boundary if I
may the red line I think it's an
indication of the the dropping land but
the owners the the site plan is a lot
closer in terms of the red line so I'm
assuming the ownership is with the site
as declared by the application forms if
I when we come to the applicant but if
we can go back to mr. Huebner I just
wanted to put that up because he did
comment about that view and so if we can
come back to mr. Huebner please if you
want to put your video up and I'll ask
the members to ask questions counselor
war boys any questions please no I think
he's quite clear thank you thank you
very much cancel the stringer any
questions no more questions thank you
thank you
that's the Norris Oh No thank you
how's the melon yes chair if I could
just ask the Parish Council chaired what
engagement did the applicant have with
the parish council about this
application I'm afraid
any other questions councilman Thank You
chair nope all right council Humphreys
no thank you moment yeah and well
councillor gold will come to you in a
minute
councillor Caston no questions madam
chair thank you thank you and no and in
fact you you raised quite a few points
of interest there for debate so thank
you very much indeed
so if you'd like to return to your
previous state of not being on our video
thank you for your time thank you very
much so we don't have any speakers or an
objector so we'll ask the applicant
Sebastian blemings if you would like to
speak please and you have three minutes
please thank you thank you yeah I'm
actually the planning ancient not the
applicant for that point and okay
firstly thanks so much for letting me an
opportunity to explain the proposals and
Mary Hart the applicant is a developer
who builds throughout the mid-south
carrier and concentrates on building
good quality homes utilizing excellent
quality materials it's not a large-scale
developer with a huge land bank he will
builder and a project out so once
procured a site the air that will
progress this this site through and it
will be built out in a timely manner the
off cold site is not yet complete and
all considered complete with this large
passive land to the north Menza site
which would obviously complete the
development there would be no incentives
for a Lieber developer to maintain this
land
and it is not approved and quad
consequently obviously that would leave
a bit of an eyesore and obviously if it
was approved or a scheme was approved
then this would provide certain
attractive entrance to the village with
the site being landscape appropriately
and we've engaged with the local
authority and very early both prior to
the submission of the previous scheme
and prior to the submission of this
scheme and this is the case with with
all that occasions that we and undertake
with an authority a predication was
meeting and the initial discussion was
actually for between two and three
dwellings on this site with a mix of
single and two-story properties and when
the formal feedback was received it
advised that two properties would be the
preferred and ruin from a planning
perspective and following concerns
raised regarding potential impact on
senior cottage during the application
and what was with being within the
application phase and we made further
concession and have agreed to remove one
of the properties and change the design
and subsequently so what what started
off with potential development of three
properties as now resulted in a proposal
for just a single dwelling it's
acknowledged that the proposed
development would occupy an elevated
position and this is not not Garcia and
we think we don't have any any concerns
with that with that point but what we
would suggest is that this design and
siting has been used to mitigate this
fact and through the position of windows
and the positions of rooms within the
dwelling to ensure that and over looking
towards see the cottages is not an issue
the proposed you now finish you've need
you're nearly up on time okay Oh also we
it'll throw that up
basically to conclude that there is a
salon scape scheme around the and the
perimeter of the site and we would be
looking to ensure that the right I think
you've now finished on your time thank
you so you've got your landscape scheme
in and we'll take note of that so um if
you could just stay there for a minute
and yes one or two people if they would
like to have questions for you so
counselor war boys
no questions Thank You Chancellor
stringer cut the questioners chair it's
about the landscaping between here and
see the cottage you said that the the
owner headaches of draconian policy
about land that's worth to them not
doing anything with it so what's gonna
happen with the piece of land between
the landscaping and the boundary of
cedar cottage I think can so that was my
question earlier when I asked the the
playing officer so you've asked a very
salient question to the right people and
I thank you
well I concern the answer that one there
is a slight discrepancy and the owner of
cedar cottage believes that he owns to
the top of the hilt having said that the
land registry information contravenes
that information the applicant has said
that he would be willing to offer this
land to senior cottage for their
benefits so it would all become within
the the ownership of cedar cottage sir
so are you telling me then your red line
of your applications right then finishes
at your landscaping and doesn't include
that little strip no I'm not saying that
it's all right okay sorry we can't take
that into account because what we have
to take into account is what is inside
the red line and the type just one other
question you suggest that you you taken
the the number of houses down in number
from two to one average three bedroom
home is one hundred square meters how
many square meters a
living accommodation does this one
dwelling there with me one second
I must confess I don't have a exact
information to hand this is can I
suggest that you work it out and come to
back to us I can certainly do that
during during the meeting if you would
please and also picking up on counsel a
string this point does the garage above
it have accommodation and yes it does so
then you calculate the square footage
for us or however you do it in meters
these days
yeah area above the garage is an ensuite
and a dressing for observing the bedroom
mm-hmm so if you can calculate that and
I'll come back to you and ask that
question
any further questions councillor
stringer sorry no chair I don't know
thank you for raising those councillor
Norris any questions for the applicant
no thank you Absalom Allen I'm just a
little concerned as well why the
applicant hasn't discussed with the
parish council it was any reason why he
didn't do that only in as much that the
original scheme was an adoption of an
adopted previous scheme if that makes
sense
discuss that later if that's your answer
to the question because I think we need
to bottom that out and I'm sure
councillor melon will bring that up in
debate further do you agree with that
way forward councillor melon yes fine no
further questions chair yeah thanks
castle Humphreys and no questions thank
you mum sure Catholic Aston no questions
madam Jeff thank you all right well I'll
come back and to mr. blemings to ask for
the meat Ridge all however it's going to
be the size and so we now move on to the
ward member if you would please
councillor Gould would you like to tell
us about this application thank you
very much madam madam chair and I've
I've been had something prepared to say
if I being busy with pencils since
hearing mr. Hooton is very clear like
account so to avoid duplication
I've thought I won't I'll try not to
make too many of the same points again
you are the would we like to hear
everything so please visit Orie sure I
decided to call in this application
following the discussion held at the
parish council and the objection that
the parish council made I also sought
advice from from planning officers the
truly the application has been amended
to provide a single dwelling rather than
the two proposed before and though the
impact of the revised application might
be considered to be reduced I think it
has been made perfectly clear the the
mass of that this is still a very
substantial building with an impact on
the neighboring cedar cottage so I
decided not to redraw the call in
request and so that the application
could benefit from the committee's
consideration now the reasons for the
call in my call in a set out in full and
a part one of the offices report and
you'll notice that the the arguments a
lot of the argit's are may draw heavily
on the advice of their heritage officer
you've seen from the photographs that
the site itself is occupies a
significant position at the entrance to
the village approaching from the be 107
7 the I to Devon M
road and the prominence of the the site
is all the greater for it being elevated
rising to a height of two meters above
the road
level no this is I think being
graphically demonstrated by the
photographs that we have seen as such
the development with overlook Nova
shading and they were shoving existing
dwellings to the north east and west of
the site and mr. Munoz has made this
clear a particular concern is the
dominance that the proposal would have
on the street scene with a considerable
impact on Cedar cottage and this
dominance and the impact its impact
would conflict with the isolated setting
of a heritage asset albeit
non-designated and the character of a
particular character of cedar cottage so
as well as the physical dominance of the
proposal that the plans are incompatible
with the design and character of Cedar
cottage not least in terms of his
particular character and scale and that
I asked the committee to consider these
points and pay particular heed to the
advice of the Heritage offer offset in
determining this application and while
it might seem odd in a sense to be
calling in a application about an
individual dwelling application and sway
I ask you to bear in mind think about
those photographs and the and the point
they make most graphically in terms of
the impact of this upon Cedar cottage
thank you very much Thank You councillor
gold so asking for comments and council
of war boys do you have any questions
yeah it's I think council gold is
actually soft produce quite clear
arguments about the proposed development
thank you
Thank You councillor stringer but no
questions for the world member
councillor Norris I have an interest in
the relationship of the height and his
proposed dwelling to the neighboring new
properties but perhaps that's one for
officers later thank you
Thank You councillor knowledge Norris
cancer melon no comment so question is
thinking Thank You councillor Humphries
I know questions well presented Thank
You councillor Caston no questions thank
you very much and myself no I don't have
any questions as such now can we come
back to Sebastian blemings have you got
that's that detail of the size of the of
the property proposed please
hello mr. blemings have you got details
of the size of the property my apologies
sorry I was on mute and it's 213 and
meters squared and that's for a
four-bedroom dwelling as I believe it
was suggested it was a three bed but
it's actually a four okay thank you very
much indeed and and so now we open for
debate and so we'll go through a first
round first for council of war boys
please yeah my response to this I did
look at before I looked at the
photographs I did look at this on a
street view and it is quite striking the
the difference in Heights between the
rear of the property and the cedar
cottage I think that the layout you look
going down Church Church Street this
isn't it well you've got this row of 8 8
very large houses and this proposed
addition to this row of houses is the
footprint is certainly as big as if not
bigger than some of those houses I I
think we do have a responsibility to
about this design and layout of
buildings and especially as there's two
things I think here one is it it it is
outside the settlement boundary the
second thing is it does affect the
context of this I've see the cottage
which though it's not listed is
considered a significant historical
asset and it and that's see the cottage
from many viewpoints looks as an
isolated cottage in the countryside and
I think this proposed development does
impinge on that it it it is a very large
building it is over and the comments
about it being overbearing and
inappropriate scale I think a very
strong ones thank you
thank you for that counselor wall bores
councillor stringer yeah I think I
slightly echo canceller war boys here I
think we heard the phrase bookend well
with development we we tend not to do
that certainly in rural areas we tend to
so try and blend things in and and the
the Skyland massing of this does seem to
be inappropriate to an age of village
setting I think probably what does help
us with this are the pictures of the
existing houses because you know if you
were going to landscape and try and
blend it into a landscape this size of
dwelling from this this road especially
you'd need to plant a well Antonio or
something you know to be able to get
anywhere near it
I think for me the the amount of benefit
from one very large family home where
you could possibly design something a
lot lower rise possibly two dwellings
there that would have been more modest
and certainly in height may have been
more appropriate to its setting I think
this one given what we've already got
coming along there which I would still
argue as to whether that was appropriate
back then that you know I remember
councillor Melvin used to say if you
think I'm ugly you should look at my
brother you know there there's and is an
element of we have an opportunity here
if we are going to go outside in the
existing settlement which in terms of
the emerging joint local plan we are
that should be an opportunity not just
replicating things that we may have
chosen different if we had our time
again thank you for that councillor
stringer council Norris yes thank you
well I'm struggling with trying to
imagine the nice and very large building
in this context it seems to me that it
would be very prominent and and it would
be helpful if it were possible to have
some sort of idea of how this would
realise
as I mentioned earlier to the existing
neighboring eight new dwellings I have a
real concern regarding the bottom would
appear to me to perceive bulk and mass
of this particular building in this
location and the overbearing effect on
Cedar College bearing in mind the
difference are in the land levels as
well
additionally we were looking at
something like a ten point seven meter
height all together through the
adjoining land so I do have real
concerns about whether this is
appropriate at all in this particular
location thank you thank you for that
councillor Norris councillor Mellon yes
thank you madam chair
yes I'm now I'm really sharing the same
concerns that have been expressed by
other members of the committee
this is to me there's a clash here
between the line of new development
properties which are all fairly big fine
they've all they've all been approved
and being built out but this one at the
end becomes almost like the biggest one
of the laws because of its position I
mean I I think they scope here for a
property but it wouldn't be this one in
my mind it would be something tucked in
towards the back of the site probably
one or one and a half stories and that
would really reduce the the sort
prominence of the development in the
landscape and the effects on cedar
cottage so what I see this potential for
development here it doesn't seem to me
that this proposed one is the
appropriate size thank you for that
councillor Humphries I'm sure thank you
I'm pretty much gonna record what
everybody else has said and can we bring
up the photograph please that was taken
so you can see the cottage on the
left-hand side and the development
that's going on right now I think it's
brought us a nice one John John brought
up four
Johnny yeah yeah sorry I just realized
you don't mean on the PowerPoint you me
the neighbor yeah yep so let me go back
[Music]
that should be on screen now any second
you are that's it yeah yeah thank you so
the top photograph so this is the
entrance to the village pretty much
isn't it and that's okay and the
developer talked about landscaping to
improve the overall view of the
development as you approach really
unless you're going to camouflage this
thing completely how can you not see it
the house that you can see with the
stuff on the roof I believe is one of
the properties that's under current
development and that's quite a far way
back from the cottage if you prefer back
to the plans now imagine this other
house which is going to be 15 meters
it's and it's its closest point to the
cottage on the left just imagine it okay
and you don't need much imagination to
actually see that that's inappropriate
sort of elevated site and it would
dominate that cottage it would dominate
the view and it would dominate what you
see as you approach that so really
historic village so I think that
photograph says pretty much everything
there houses on the rest of the
development I actually like a nurse in
the either be hold of I actually like
the properties I just don't see that
it's appropriate but whoever one early
15 meters on an elevated position to
that historic cottage it's just not
right and and I think that's what it
comes down to this comes down to it's
just not right
it comes down to common sense and it
comes down to just looking at and go
look this is clearly obviously not right
and we must have the moral courage I
think to oppose it mainly because of its
dominance issues and its location
anywhere else to be a great house but on
a celebrated position close to that
concept is not if you go into page 201
which is 5.1 design layout impact on
street scene it talks there about how
we're not going to impose
look through our windows and see into
the cottage and all the other stuff what
it doesn't talk about I don't think is
how you would feel living in that
cottage looking out on this domineering
building pretty much any garden it
doesn't talk about the lack of that
sunlight as it comes around during the
summer and winter months especially the
winter so it's all about the house it's
not about the cottage nothing's wrong so
we've got to think about the occupants
as well this just isn't right and it
doesn't matter what landscape and you
bring in it still won't be right and
again I'll refer to that top photograph
and just think about what another house
would look like 15 metres from the
cottage on the left and you probably
came to the same conclusion thank you
Thank You councillor Humphreys
councillor Caston yes so ya have issues
with this former design and layout point
of view it's um it does seem to have a
certain amount of overlooking issues but
I think mainly my issue is the
overshadowing due to the orientation
like the Yemen that that um the the the
trees will almost certainly cause more
of an overshadowing problem we've got am
an older design of house in Cedars
cottage and these older houses require
more light than a normal house because
of the design there's smaller windows
the more the more light you get the
better the environment is and I believe
that this development with the height of
it with the trees for screening would
take such a huge amount of light out of
that building that that'd be completely
unacceptable the the other issue is the
protection of a historic building which
really goes hand in hand it is a non
designated historic asset but I think it
needs protecting for a moment but this
old shadowing and turning it into an a
lesser environment to live in
so that's where I am on it
thank you for that counselor Caston well
I've made several notes here and they've
all been brought up really by everybody
on page 200 it tells us about a
sufficient number and range of homes to
provide needs of the present and future
generations these are huge and I think
villages like this needs some smaller
properties further landscaping which
councillor Caston is just alluded to and
we can't change what's already there we
accept that but if you put some further
landscaping along shall we say the back
of the cottage it's just going to
enclose them even further and what about
I did ask the officer for angles on
lighten things because they've got solar
panels on the back there I also note
that the Heritage have asked about the
question of size and members have
brought up the amount that the size of
this and I have to say this is a DejaVu
application as far as I'm concerned and
it would be I have something in demonym
that's going to appeal at the moment and
it would just be like prisoner cellblock
H to be sort of squashed in crowded in I
I find it very difficult I did I have to
own up I did drive past her the other
day to get some eggs from the automatic
egg machine and when I came back and
looked at that site from the corner
that's what horrified me more which is
why we have that those two late pictures
up sorry I don't think this is right
also the garden everybody's saying
there's no overlooking from the houses
but the little cottage has velop swen
work here Velux windows and if they open
them during the day anybody in the
garden could just look straight into
their house and unfortunately the
applicant tells us that well if it's not
going to be built on it he looked
terrible um that's not a planning reason
so I'm very disappointed
with this I heard what cancer melanin
said about there might be room for a
property but I'm not so sure about that
myself but then you'd have to look at
that if it came again so I I can't
support this as it stands and that's my
view on it so we've all spoken does
anybody want to make a proposal who's
that whispering all right counselor
stringer yes sorry we didn't see where
are you oh yeah I didn't want to take up
your bandwidth yeah I think there's
elements here that you know clearly I
think we're feeling enough is enough and
we but we also have policies to back
this up absolutely I think there needs
to be a recognition of where the built
form of this village is with now I would
say lady in stone yet because it hasn't
been through consultations but we've
we've had creep of development through
the years of no longer having a
five-year land supply and needing to be
compliant with the NPP I totally
understand that but there has to be a
balance struck and when you get to the
age of settlements I think that's where
you need to strike that and be even more
sensitive and you can see from this one
from that shot across the corner how
even what we have already agreed to is I
would say possibly beyond the limit
which means you really need to be
sensitive so I I'm not saying nothing
should ever be built on this parcel of
land when are mine saying if anything
comes about here he's got to clearly
demonstrate how it's going to improve
the lot at the moment and actually
deliver something that this village
actually desperately needs because the
officer said oh this won't have to
comply with seal yeah which is because
it has to comply with seal doesn't mean
to say it gives up any money to help
this this number of dwellings like this
that do not have to pay a penny because
of how how they're constructed so we
need to be careful of that as a plus so
having weighed up the pluses of saying
yes to another develop
yeah and and the minuses bring about the
minuses for me far outweigh the plus I
think this is this is not appropriate to
its setting I think it's completely out
of character with the village although
it could be argued it's in character
with what's already being built along
their age so and equally I think we need
to protect the edge of settlement so I
find this totally inappropriate to its
setting I think it's also not a
brilliant although the the design
concept I quite like I like the idea of
things looking like buttons I'm yeah
quite a brutalist in that area myself
that's a good approach but it has to be
appropriate to its setting and and
frankly the landowner says I will let
this all grow up with weaves and
whatever you actually would call that a
wildflower meadow that'd be brilliant
right on that corner so you know really
really really can't support this in any
way shape or form and would happily move
refusal based on policy a GP one norm h
bo2 is normally another age 16 yet is
certainly that residential I mean as
council gathering if you stood in that
garden let alone bounced up and down on
trampoline
you'd be able to physically look if not
bounce completely into those open
village windows that's it's it's that's
really not appropriate there so we're
not saying never but what we're saying
is that would need to be really
respectful of the whole of their area
not just respectful to the ones already
built
thank you for that councillor and I
think did I not see this is where I get
in a muddle did I see councillor
Humphrey came first and then councillor
Caston was that right yes councillor
Humphrey thank you madam chair was that
a proposal was the first question yes
yes I'd like to second it and I all your
points absolutely appropriate also if
you look at the MPP F where it talks
about three-dimensional development even
though the officer argues here I would
actually argue that it doesn't
contribute to protecting or enhancing
the built or historic environment and
that's another reason for refusal so I
would
second the proposal for refusal and then
sorry counselor Kirsten I think we might
have usurped you a bit
yes um thank you madam chairman I was
just um I was going to say if I did
second it that we could add HB 1 to the
policies that this that makes this
unacceptable
if the councilors some wish to historic
buildings can I also ask John Koeppen
gee because I mean if if people want to
put up fences and things we don't want
them to be blocked in you know if that
comes back as an alternative just before
we go one a little bit further can I
just ask John for that please yes so
there's a column aspects here I'll come
back to HP one in a moment the just a
bit we would talk about landscaping a
lot and we've talked about the
relationship between the two there's a
couple of governing factors here we need
to bear in mind at the moment this is
Nova cultural field anyone can plant
whatever they want in that context so
you could put a whole lot of trees a
whole lot of hedges and you can also put
a fence up to two meters high along the
boundary wherever that boundary is not
disputed to be now that might be at the
top of the bank or it might be the
bottom but ultimately there is there is
that in terms of what he's committed
development and that is a material
consideration so if that would be a
vexatious activity to do that no if you
are if a reason for refusal is based on
the harm of overlooking from a person
standing in the new garden and yet
permitted development would allow a
2-meter fence that would block that harm
I would say that we are in we would be
in a poor position to defend and appeal
on my basis your proposal you're shaking
your head say your bit please no string
to speak just a minute please
yeah just to say it wasn't about the it
was the the normal use of a garden
people play on things I don't know you
can restrict permit the development
right and all that nonsense
but you
can stock children putting boxes on
things and climbing on things and all
that and that will directly overlook
this garden to such an extent because of
the topography if this was a level flat
field this wouldn't be an issue but the
facts from ground level you already
above those windows I think that is that
is the problem yes so what you're
talking about there is the intrusive
impact on amenity as a whole and I
probably yes so um but I think just you
need to be careful about specifics and
general amenity and I wanted to be
careful with how we word that through
before I get onto the hb1 can I also
just talk about the local plan the
emerging local plan if members are
looking to include that in a reason for
refusal that is fine but in terms of
that's a potential thing you could do
but just bear in mind that at this
current iteration of the current
emerging to a local plan there is a
provision for infill development in
linear lines of ten houses and I believe
this would qualify so I want to be
careful with any pulling in of the
emerging local plan and I have to go and
think about that if that's where members
want to go however you have been talking
about the setting and the enjoyment of
cedar cottage now it is a non designated
heritage asset hb1 is a bit of an
interesting policy because it's
basically I'll read out what it states
the district playing authority places a
high priority on protecting the
character and appearance of all
buildings of architectural or historic
interest
full-stop particular attention will be
given to the protection of the setting
of listed buildings this is not a listed
building so that part would not really
apply but the first sentence that we
place a high priority on the protection
of the character on historic interest
would apply so you could apply HB 1 in
at least in part you're happy with that
Andrea Cantillo strained are you happy
with that and cancelosi you have what's
been
yeah I keep going back to the MPP a
paragraph a which talks about those the
three-dimensional development and it's
the harm to the historic setting and it
doesn't enhance so it doesn't handoff
built or historic environment so if
there's a lot of ways this so anything
can I'd say fantastic but yeah and also
don't forget the parish counselor did
say about the setting of the buildings
opposite which I think also need to be
taken into reflection yeah I don't mean
you to add anything to it but I think
it's all part of it no agreed and I
don't believe we should worry about the
fence we shouldn't worry about the trees
or anything like that let's just deal
with what we're here for
which is this application for this
particular property and I think we've
got enough there to go for refusal so
can you drum up some words for us John
will give you a few moments and then I
don't think unless anybody wants to
state anything else I'll allow you to
put your hands up if you need to say
anything of great importance no good
okay
may I ask one more question to madam
chair if I may
overlooking is that part of the garden
into the would you agree angeles
stringer but not from the house itself
and the the arts windows of the poster
plumbing well the issue is any window on
that side that can be within two meters
of a floor has the capability of
directly looking down into see the
cottage and - i need to ask what is the
amenity area of cedar cottage where do
they sit in the sunshine in a deck chair
you know because their garden their rear
garden it's less than two meters wide
they sit to the side so did anyone
looking at any window at first floor
level at the back of that building is
going to directly look at these people
at less than 20 meters you know and we
normally try and avoid direct looking
into windows about 21 meters don't be
John and this this I think would you
know it's because of the limited amenity
area I've seen a cottage before we even
stopped I think so
any impingement into their amenity area
from overlooking is devastating to that
property it's not that's not common to
many properties but it certainly is to
this one right okay I think I've got
most of you speak again I see your hand
or is that from beef oh I just wanted to
agree with counselor stringer I think
the fact that the roof lights of the of
the proposed development are not only
their lower down on the on the floor
level of the second floor I think that
I'd definitely say that there would be
some degree of overlooking thank you
okay so if I was to suggest given what I
have heard in respect of a reason take
forward I may put it something like this
the proposed dwelling if approved would
represent a overly dominant development
out of scale with the character of the
prevailing existing dwellings with
particular harmful impact on the raw
setting an enjoyment of occupiers of
cedar cottage a non designated heritage
asset and this includes impact on their
privacy
furthermore the detrimental or intrusive
impact and harm on amenity is made worse
by the provision and scale of the
development on higher land compared to
existing development on this basis the
development is considered contrary to
and I would give you the following
policies I feel irrelevant h16 which was
the first version to amenity h13 h15
talks about appropriate development and
design GP 1 which is also design HB 1
which is historic setting of the local
plan and I would go on to add to that FC
1 and 1.1 of the focus review that
refers to development needing to enhance
the area for design purposes as well as
being contrary to chapter 12 and that's
the entire design chapter of
the NPP F with particular reference to
paragraphs 1 to 7 and 130 that talk
about refusal of bad design and layout
the limited public benefit of one
dwelling is not considered to outweigh
the harm identified would that be
sufficient when this sounds good enough
to me propose are you happy about that
yeah 2nd Baron counselor Humphreys yes
thank you
right in that case then can we go to the
governance officer to do a roll call on
the matter in hand thank you thank you
Jeff if you could please respond with
for against or abstain
so counsel James Carson again can we
make it clear what we're voting for so
we'll start again sure if that's not
just for clarity's sake can we just get
clarity with in Despres this seems to
have been a bit of a mistake and we need
clarity well is yes we've had refused
yes I thought so so that case members
who wish to refuse should obviously vote
for this resolution I think I think
councillor Caston confused yeah I did
get confused
I'd like before the proposal to refuse
the application please so so counts so
Ian to pray can we take that vote again
because of the and yes I think I think
so agree I think mr. Carmichael is as
well I think we and member corrects
themselves and we here that's absolutely
councillor Caston just confirms again
the way he intends to vote and I will
record that and yet for the proposal on
the table to refuse doesn't it counselor
cursory for the proposal on the table to
refuse
Kasper Humphries for Haslam Ellen for
Casa Norris for councillor stringer for
and councillor war boys for the proposal
Thank You counselors that's unanimous
chair mr. Dupree yes indeed unanimous
vote for the proposal to refuse thank
you that's very clear so I now move on
to see if there are any site inspections
none received chair thank you in that
case then I now formally closed the
meeting but thank everyone for their
patience and attendance and input today
thank you very much indeed thank you